Hello everybody!
Alright, I'm gonna need you guys help for this because I realized...
While I was like... by the way I'm still at my old place right now because I haven't moved my PC setup yet.
So like... I basically have to commute back and forth.
I have to take public transport and commute back and forth to stream right now.
Alright, by the way I need your help guys because like...
I bought a new mic cable because I realized I've been...
Yes guys, I had to take public transport.
I was so confused because like... I haven't taken public transport in a very long time.
Because like... you know, since like university wise.
And then like... I had to google.
I was like...
How to pay for bus.
Because I was like... I cannot keep Ubering.
I cannot... I cannot keep Ubering.
I don't know!
I was like...
What do they need to pay for bus?
I don't know.
I was worried rules changed.
I was worried the rules have changed.
And I wanted to be sure because I was like...
Oh my god, I don't have... who carries cash?
I was like... who carries cash?
I don't have to pay for bus anymore.
How do I pay for bus?
Because in the university...
They give you like bus passes in university.
So I never had to like... figure out how to pay bus.
I was like... how do people outside of university pay for bus?
Like... I don't carry cash anymore.
I don't carry... I do carry like a little bit of cash.
Just for like emergencies.
Because like... you know...
What if like card readers...
What if like... Y2K happened...
But like... it was too... like you know...
It was just delayed.
What if Y2K meant 2024 during August or some shit.
And then... I was just like...
I was like... oh yeah... I should carry a little bit of cash.
So... so I... I have...
But they're like...
They're like $50 bills.
They're like $50 to
the bus driver.
Like... I mean, they deserve more.
But like... I'm not...
I'm not the one gonna give them.
I agree that they deserve more... more.
But I'm not gonna give fucking $50.
Why 50?
I don't know.
Because I don't wanna carry change.
That's why.
Why carry 5, $10 bills...
When I can carry one $50 bill.
Oh, I know I have several $50 bills in there.
Like...
So Sound Guy, you know, let me know if I'm like snapping or crackling because I did buy...
I bought a new like microphone cable and I like rearrange the cables for a little bit.
Like I know it's like why do you have to rearrange your cables?
Because like you're going to move anyway, like you're going to move this setup anyway.
Well, well, I have to be here for like a week.
Okay.
Until this... until like... I'm not going to like suddenly a bit echoey.
Yeah, there's like nothing here anymore.
There's nothing here to sound for me.
My room is literally... is literally like the PC setup right now.
Like everything's almost gone.
It's literally just the PC here.
So there's... there's almost no furniture anymore or like, you know, my...
like my dokimers like acting as like Sound Guard and everything.
So I mean there's still stuff here.
There's actually still stuff here.
It's just like not as much as it used to be because like I said like...
Like I said, I moved around.
A lot of like I already moved.
I'd have like 20% left.
I've 20% left in the... in my... my room alone.
So...
So that's why it is a little bit echoey right now.
It's just a little... I'm sorry.
I don't know what to do.
I'm not going to put stuff... you're going to have to deal with that for... for a week.
Okay guys, you're going to have to deal with the... look it's... I'm a... it's been a... I'm a mess.
Okay.
I'm a...
I literally googled how... how to pay for bus.
Guys.
I...
Guys, please.
I'm getting further... the longer I stream the less relatable I'm being guys.
Oh my God.
Oh, yeah, by the way, I want to talk about this real quick.
Like this has nothing to do with Apex.
I just want to talk about it because like I thought...
I just want to talk about it because like I thought it was really funny and the Olympia...
the...
was it the IOC?
That's the International Olympic Committee is trying to like hide it and has been filing takedowns of it like everywhere.
But do you guys see that part of that guy who failed the the high jump because his dick was too big?
Did you guys see that?
And then the funniest shit is that they did the... what was it?
The Streisand effect?
The Olympics did the Streisand effect on it and tried to file takedowns everywhere of the video.
So like people are like, I'm like, why would you do that?
Not everybody is going to post it everywhere now.
Yeah, the I... the Olympics has been like... yeah, the Olympics has been fucking DMCAing every tweet and video of that guy.
So like, like it's like those those like high jump thing where like you need a stick to get over like the pole.
I want to talk about it because I DMCA this Olympics.
I want to talk about it because like if the Olympics actually DMCA or takedown this stream, that's a story I can tell and like that's just going to make me like more relevant because...
But if they don't then I spread...
I'm going to spread the news so that it'll still so people will know they can't censor this.
This is important news.
Okay, they try to censor it.
So I'm trying to make sure everybody knows.
But yeah, yeah, it's actually crazy.
It's like one of those like the jump thing where like the pole, the pole, like, you know, we have to jump over like this like, what's it called?
Like the the the fuck is that called the little pole thing, you know, like use a pole to jump over a separate pole and then like he almost got over it.
The pole bot.
Yeah, he almost got over it.
But then like his peepee was just too big and it like touched it and then he fell.
I thought it was like the fucking funniest shit ever because people were like damn man.
You can't you can't be thinking those thoughts and then others were like bro.
He was.
I was like what the fuck?
That's crazy.
Holy shit.
That's actually crazy.
I was like, oh my God.
And then the IOC started filing takedowns and DMCA's and I was like, oh my God.
Now everybody will know about this man.
I was like, oh my God.
I don't know if I could find it's so funny, but I don't know if there's like if there's like videos of it still existing because they actually even need a pole.
The thing is I don't know if like oh there it is.
This this is I thought this over here.
Here you go guys.
It existed.
I found it guys.
This is the news that also the other guy that fucking failed the pole vault very sadly the one that like he tried to jump on it and then and then he didn't even like get on top of the pole.
Like it was so sad.
This is so sad.
I tweeted.
I posted a link in chat.
I want to thank you.
You don't keep most popular man in the Olympic Village.
It's because of massive dog.
Hey, thank you.
This is Richard.
Thank you.
Big peepee problems.
Couldn't be.
He.
I think you're the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you to be fair.
They should have took this peepee better.
What if it was already?
You know, it's like the first thing you would and you know, that was your Olympic athlete and you know, this is an issue.
I feel like this is already as best as they could do.
Like the comments.
This is unfortunate or is it?
Oh my God.
Oh, it's it's so.
I just want to know like casting wise like how?
How did you get?
What?
The thing?
Okay.
There's the other one to the pole fall goes hard guys is actually funny.
The the pole actually goes so hard because this is this is the other one that that happened.
This was before this was before but I was just like, oh my God, it's so sad.
It's just like, oh no.
Oh, you're so sad when I saw that.
Because that's before and then like and then and then the other one happened and it was like, oh no, you couldn't get over.
I was like, I don't think that's supposed to happen.
You're supposed to go over.
Oh my God.
Yeah, that was like, that was so sad when I saw that the pulse.
I like the comments though.
They finally I like how someone was like they finally allowed the average guy to compete at the only thing.
That's like literally I found out about the other dude because I was looking at the Twitter replies and everyone and then they're like, oh, hey, that's nearly as funny as the other dude knocking the bar off with his boner and I saw that I was like, what?
And then I saw that video.
Oh, oh, oh,
anyway, that's my daily Olympic update for you guys that all right.
Anyway, let's talk about apex versus the guy tells you not to worry about no.
But yes, I let me know if I start crackling again and then if it's okay, okay, then that means I fixed the problem.
Uh, uh, don't worry.
I give you guys the Olympic news that matters.
Uh, also, you guys, you guys remember my talk about listen the river and they decide to fucking swim in the river.
Apparently, some of the athletes contracted E.
Coli after swimming in the sand.
I told you I told you this.
You can say you fixed it.
You fix the River, You can never fix 2,000 years of shit!
Yeah!
Like some athletes contracted E.coli.
I was like, oh my god, you see videos of them throwing up after swimming there.
Oh my god.
Yeah, who would have thought?
I fucking called it.
I called it!
I was like, I would never swim in that river.
I don't care how like they spent like a billion dollars cleaning up the shit in the river.
Like cleaning up like everything there, but like I was like no matter what also like the people protesting and stuff.
Like I don't care I'm not...
Like you can tell me you spent a billion dollars trying to clean up, clean it up.
But like alright, it's still this river.
There's no fixing that river.
There's no...
That river ain't good anymore.
Yeah, they've spent like a billion dollars.
That's why people were... I mean to be fair for every Olympic, for every country that hosts the Olympics, there will always be somebody... there will always be a group of people complaining because they spend... a lot of countries tend to go into debt after.
Same with like the World Cup for soccer slash football.
That's why people complain a lot for those who are not fans of those particular sports because they spent billions of dollars making like stuff for it.
And then yeah, and then like some countries actually go into debt after after like whatever fucking sport happens.
So there's always protests about it.
And I don't... someone said, it's not true, but like I don't know.
I bet like there's a lot of people in Paris.
Because like people were like we should protest by shitting in the river during the events.
And I'm like there's someone... I remember like someone in my chat was like that's not true.
It was just like they were just... it was just propaganda.
I was like there's a lot of people in Paris.
It only takes one crazy person to shit in the river.
Like...
That's all... that's all I'm saying.
Like it only takes one person to be...
I don't care if you drink it.
It's just people are just saying it.
Yeah, so that's that's my daily Olympic news.
It's a big river.
And the river got one guide.
Alright.
To be fair, I bet you a lot of animals are doing... I mean when you're flying, the birds are flying.
And then the birds flying.
And like...
I'm pretty sure there is bird poop in that river, too.
That's why like...
Honestly, all rivers are dangerous.
Alright, one last Olympic update.
I just find it...
Like a lot of people are talking about like, the sharpshooters.
But there's like so many funny shit happening outside of that.
Because there was one guy, the canoe rower, I don't know if you guys saw it, But there was like one guy, the canoe rower.
I was like, I don't think you should flex that.
He was like, finally!
I have a medal that represents my rank!
And like, his rank was bronze in League of Legends.
And I was like, bro, that's not a flex vest!
Not a win flex bro.
Yes.
Oh my god.
I like how somebody was like, no it was gold.
Bro, it's still not a flex vest!
It doesn't matter, bronze, silver or gold.
It's not very high elo.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I just thought it was really funny.
I'm not so funny.
Oh my god.
And it had to be League of All Games.
Why would you do that?
Why would you play League of Legends?
Right after the Olympics.
I don't know.
I would say Overwatch is torture.
But I feel like League in itself is one of the circles of hell.
Like, right after the Olympics, he went straight to League.
League player, I touched grass.
I was just like, oh my god.
That's absolutely crazy.
I don't know how he has the fucking...
Like, mental for League right after.
Alright, anyway.
Apex!
Apex updates.
So, I know I should have been...
This is like daily updates.
Daily Olympic updates.
Anyway.
Apex update now.
I am so proud of myself that I did not leak the map.
I knew about the new map for a long time.
Like...
So, I'm very proud of myself that I did not leak it.
I wanted to talk about it, but I couldn't.
But I knew about this map for a while now.
How long ago?
Well...
It was during...
Because like, the test for this map was during...
What's her name?
What the fuck is her name again?
Zicalis?
Shield girl.
Whoa!
Oh, so different.
Sorry, I should...
I stopped like...
Conduit!
God, I stopped caring about their names.
There's just too many now.
I stopped...
I just called them by nicknames now.
There's too...
I...
Guys, my mind is mush, guys.
So, like, I stopped caring about remembering names.
So, that new map has been teased for us since Conduit playtesting.
So, that's how long ago this new map's been in development.
So, I had to keep that secret for a very long time.
Because I knew about it during Conduit's playtest.
Because it was done at the same time.
Uh...
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
So, that's why I was like...
I was like, I'm so happy it's finally out.
So, I don't have to like think about it anymore.
I don't have to think about like...
Uh...
So, I meant Conduit, not Catalyst.
So, I don't have to like think about like...
Try and make sure I don't accidentally leak the new map.
Because I accidentally leaked some game modes in the past before.
But I stopped myself.
I never like actually leaked anything.
I once like almost very close, but I stopped myself.
Anyway, they nerfed aim assist by apparently a lot.
Like, I mean it's like 10 to 20%.
10 to 15%, I think.
So, they nerfed aim assist and made it so that...
Um...
So that, uh...
If you're from PlayOnConsole, you have like a 10% nerf or something.
I don't fucking know.
Like, I should just...
I should actually read the patch notes.
Guys, I'm a professional.
Okay.
Ipex Legends!
Patch notes!
And then...
25% for PC.
So, you're playing on controller on PC.
Your aim assist gets nerfed by 25%.
Thank fucking...
Thank...
Oh my god.
I'm gonna see how hard it's gonna hit.
Like...
Bye, ELO.
Um...
No, they nerfed console too.
I was reading it.
Um...
I even sent a link to it.
Uh...
What was it?
Where the fuck did I link it?
Uh...
Cause I was reading the patch notes.
The patch...
The...
Okay.
Console crossplay.
It's only if it's console and you're in a PC lobby.
Which is basically my lobby.
And your...
Your aim assist got reduced by 18%.
So, if you're on console and you queue into my fucking lobbies, like...
18%.
It's reduced by 18%.
And usually in my lobbies, a lot of this is like...
Um...
What's that word?
It's like...
Reflex now.
You know?
Reflex.
Like...
What's that word when you're...
Uh...
When you're playing for a while and then like...
It's just...
Um...
It's just inner instinct.
By then.
So like...
Because it's not adjusted.
It got adjusted.
Uh...
No, not habit.
Is it instinct?
Muscle memory.
Yes!
That's gonna fuck up with a lot of people's muscle memory.
And that's what I'm gonna enjoy.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm still gonna get shit on because I don't play as much anymore.
Cause I...
I'm so busy.
But like...
I don't...
I could like...
I could like talk shit right now and I'm gonna get shit on because...
But like...
What I'm hoping for is that...
A lot of console players and controller players right now...
It's affecting their muscle memory.
Because like...
You know...
One tiny adjustment fucks up...
Fucks you up.
Like...
I've had that happen so much.
Especially like changing senses and like...
Playing around with different senses.
Or like playing different games.
Um...
Back...
Like back to back.
And like you're not adjusting it.
So I'm hoping...
I'm hoping a lot of console and controller players...
Are like...
Having a rough time right now.
Adjusting to that nerf.
So...
Let's see how that works.
Anyway, there's a new map.
It's a city.
Um...
It's a city and there's apparently...
There's a lot of high ground.
Um...
Let's see.
There's a new class perk for controller class.
What is it?
Zone overcharge.
Controller legends now have extra shield capacity when playing in zone.
The zone automatically grants...
What the fuck?
Okay, who's a controller?
Wait, what?
Oh!
So these guys will have extra shield.
Okay.
Yeah, they're gonna have extra shield when they're in zone.
Okay, what else?
Uh...
Cast with permanent when the...
Okay, if you're in zone, you have 25 extra shield.
Uh...
And you can heal this.
Okay.
Uh...
Okay, that's it.
Oh, but...
If you have red armor, it doesn't matter.
Okay.
That's a little bit broken, but okay.
I mean, okay.
What else?
Oh, everybody has a new class.
Wait, they read...
Adjusted stuff.
Okay, let's see.
Recon legends can now gain threat vision when aiming down sight.
Threat vision will highlight enemies that the character has.
Line of sight to whatever you want.
I don't know.
How is that helpful?
Like, I can see them.
How is that?
I don't understand.
I guess like, I've never seen that as an issue before.
Aiming, that's for me?
But what if I'm blind?
Yeah, it doesn't work through walls or smoke.
So like...
I guess like, for those...
Because I'm just like...
Do I... I don't need that.
I'm just thinking, I guess people who don't play the game as...
I guess this is more like, beginner friendly.
Because like, when you...
When you can see people move.
Like, the moment they're moving, you can see them.
I guess...
Oh!
Rats.
You can use those to find rats.
I guess.
I think that would be really helpful for finding rats.
If it highlights enemies and you just look around.
You just like, randomly look around and then you'll see...
Like, it'll just glow.
But that fucking sucks.
Like, actually...
That fucking sucks.
Actually...
Um...
Survey beacon...
Shortening range of 500 meters when scanning the entire map.
No longer randomly distributed and all will now be turned on with every map scanning now.
Oh!
Survey beacons will be for everything.
Okay.
It'll grant less evil.
Alright, what else?
Stat trackers.
Shockwave.
Okay, we don't care about that.
Balances.
Eva 8 is back on the floor.
R9!
Oh, thank fucking god.
The R9 buffed.
Damage falloff?
On R9?
Bro, they casted it!
What?
Is that fair?
I don't play Apex for realism.
I don't...
Stop adding realism!
No one likes damage falloff.
Nobody ever likes damage falloff.
That shit fucking sucks.
Like, if you would add more realism, add blood.
Like, what?
Bro, that fucking sucks.
R9 was already nerfed.
Come on.
Um...
Oh yeah, and then you can have...
Uh...
You can have...
Apparently, you can have...
Uh...
Two pistols at the same time.
So, you can have Mozamm and...
I knew about that during the playtesting.
So, that's why I was really worried about leaking that as well.
I knew that from...
They've been playtesting that for a while.
Um...
Alright.
Is that it?
Is that everything?
Uh...
Buh buh buh...
Buh buh...
Dual wield...
LMGs...
Alright!
Let's go!
Oh, they redid the spread for shotgun.
Is that everything?
Important?
Guys, is there anything else I should know?
Uh...
Oh!
Crypto!
Crypto becomes cloaked when in drone?
What the fuck?
Is crypto...
They made invisible crypto!
They...
What?
They made invisible?
Crypto!
Oh!
All LMGs now...
New hop-up.
Gun shield generator?
What the fuck?
What do I need?
He's off the grid!
Oh my god!
They bugged Crypto!
Yeah!
He's invisible now.
Went hidden from sight.
Okay.
Alright.
You can't see that.
Is there...
What else?
Um...
I wish all crypto is invisible.
I wish crypto was invisible twenty-four.
Number seven.
Alright, what other stuff that's new?
Guys, oh my god!
This in- what the fuck?
Everything now regenerates shield charge?
Wait, power pylon now regenerates shield charge?
Um, so does that mean...
Uhhhh...
Does that mean like, faster and more resilient?
Wait, does that mean like, it doesn't- Oh, it regenerates the shield charge for...
Uh...
25- Oh, the controller stuff.
Yeah, yeah.
I was gonna say, like, oh I thought they meant like, in general.
I was like, no, that's fucked up.
Uh, no longer requires LS2 echo to launch?
Oh!
You don't have to look at- You don't have to look at echo anymore.
That's nice.
Jesus Christ, there's so much shit.
Like, there's so much!
I'm like, reading through it, I'm like, what the fuck?
There's so many changes.
Yeah, I- I was gonna say, I thought it meant like, it never runs out.
That's what I thought for the Watson upgrade.
I was like, there's no fucking way they just did that.
Alright, let's go to the training range.
Oh, bot royale.
Let's go to the firing range real fast.
So I can check out some of the new updates.
Let's see.
Alright.
Let's try it out.
Alright, uh...
Uh, Bot Royale.
Bot Royale is basically for, you know in the tutorial, you get to play with bots.
Uh, like you have to play like, several games with bots.
That's just that, but now you can choose it.
Now like people can, uh, do, uh, highlights and like, frag videos with Bot Royale, and people won't know.
They can, now they can fake the bot, they can fake cool, uh, montages in Bot Royale.
Like...
That was a problem back then, I remember.
Alright, let's see, what's the hop-up?
Oh, Gun Shield, okay.
Um...
Let's see...
It was Car, right?
Car has...
It's... Oh no, it was Elsa?
Oh, Star has it?
Oh my god, it's Bastion!
It...
What the fuck?
Bro, does it re... Okay, you have to be ADS for it, okay.
Alright, I'm just thinking like, do you really need that though?
Oh my god, I'm Bastion!
I'm, I'm beta Bastion!
Holy shit!
That's fucking crazy!
Oh my god!
Okay, who, which...
Other gun has it?
Uh...
Rampage?
No!
Rampage did not need that!
Rampage!
No!
Wait!
Can I have double shield as Gibby?
Wait a minute!
Okay, let's see, it's Rampage...
And Spitfire.
Oh no, Rampage and Spitfire does not need that!
It doesn't!
Oh!
Okay.
Alright, let's see.
Do I get double shield?
Does that mean I get double shield?
Oh wait, no, I need to... I'm gonna grab Rampage.
Oh!
Wait, it's gold!
Wait!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, take me now!
Oh my god, I can snag... Oh my god!
That's fucking crazy!
Holy shit, it's gold!
It's gold!
Alright, let's see.
Um... Spitfire.
Alright.
Spitfire.
Oh my god, it's gold!
Get killed me now!
Oh god, Gibby is back!
Try LMG, Hitfire.
It doesn't show up for Hitfire.
See?
That doesn't show up.
It only shows up for ADS.
Oh!
Piss fights!
I love looking... I love looking through Apex and Pissvision.
Okay.
Um... LMG, Hitfire gets more accurate now.
Does it really?
Oh, I... I don't use Hitfire that often on LMG.
So, it's hard to notice.
I mean, I do when I'm like, literally like here.
But, I very rarely use it up here.
Because like I said, like you know, because Hitfire has been dog shit.
I guess you're right.
I mean, it does feel like...
It does feel like, you know...
It does feel more accurate.
But like I said, I always do.
Uh... Wait, did the record go shrink?
Oh, it did!
That's interesting!
Yeah!
It is like more casual friendly.
Which makes sense.
Because it's the casuals that spend money.
I don't spend money on this game.
Why cater to me?
All I'm saying is I don't spend money.
They have no reason to cater to me.
Alright, let's see.
Uh...
Someone said try devotion.
Alright.
What is devotion?
Is it piss color too?
Jesus.
It's just get bouncing.
Don't say that!
It's fine.
Say it.
It's okay.
I'm for the people.
My opinions reflect the casuals too.
Guys, don't worry.
I'm just like you guys now.
I'm just like you guys.
Alright.
The sponsors.
It's because the sponsors treat me so well.
That I never have to spend money anymore.
Oh my god.
The reticle thing?
But like...
I would still like...
I would still like aim with...
Aim with this.
Yeah, I still aim with ADS though.
I hope the game volume has been...
Alright, I'll make sure the game volume is okay.
Alright, what other stuff they did?
Oh yeah!
Invisible Crypto.
Am I invisible?
How do I... enter.
You can tell I don't play Crypto.
Where am I?
Wait, how do I...
No, I see myself.
It's fucked up.
I can see myself.
So like, I guess like...
They can't see this.
If I stand in the middle...
Does that mean they don't see me?
Like...
If I just...
Oh, I have to upgrade!
Okay.
Where is it?
Oh, off the grid!
What was it before?
What was it?
I don't even use...
Oh wait.
Watch me disappear, guys.
Wait, I still see me.
What is this?
Okay.
Scout's drone.
Scanned.
Persists through.
Do they change any of these?
I guess not.
Alright, so I could literally um, get out, and go back in.
Okay.
Alright.
Off the grid...
Aaahhhhhhhh!
You guys wanna see a magic trick?
Where did he go?
Where did he go?!
Wooooooo!
Where is here?
Where did she go?
Where did Toki go?
She went off the grid!
She burned off her fingerprints!
She's gone!
African tabra!
Oh my god!
Her fingerprints are gone!
I don't want to play crypto and just stand in the middle of a fight.
African tabra!
She escaped in front of her eyes.
What if I just...
Oh my god!
What if I hide a drone?
I go into a rat spot, I put my drone out, and just...
Okay, but I feel like people are going to see my drone and just shoot.
And then just actively try to find me because of it.
No carbon footprint drone.
I would absolutely die.
Despite how confident I sound right now, I know if I do that in a real game, I'd get absolutely shit on.
Like, hide the drone.
Dude, the drone was scammed no matter what!
And then when they hear the scan, people are going to be like, Drone!
And then they'll see me.
They'll kill the drone and then they'll see me.
Like, what the fuck?
What else?
Is there anything else?
Is there anything else I'm missing?
Yeah, Bloodhour run me down.
That is so true.
It's like...
Is that?
Oh, that's the highlight?
Well, that shit sucks.
Sorry, hate.
I don't like that.
It feels like I'm down learning.
Oh, the Akeem.
Yeah.
I forgot about the dual weapon.
What is it?
Is it a hop-up or...
Uh...
Oh no, I can just grab two right now.
Wow!
Oh, it takes one slide?
Alright.
Okay.
Holy shit!
Merry Christmas!
Okay, so I can do shotgun and...
Okay, no.
Only shot... double shotguns.
Okay.
Dual Mozamb.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I don't like the dual Mozamb.
The dual Mozamb feels fucking weird.
ADS style.
I think like...
I think hipfire is okay.
But definitely the ADS...
ADS feels weird.
I think.
I think the ADS feels a little weird.
Uh...
Nice.
You only do pistols.
Uh...
It's P20 and Mozamb, right?
You only do... yeah.
You only do P20 and Mozamb.
But like, one or the other.
Now do it with attachments.
Ooh, true.
Let's see.
Do I need...
double?
No, I just need one!
Oh!
I just need one!
That's good.
Nice.
And then...
Ooh, hammerpoint.
That sounds broken.
Alright.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Alright.
That shit seems very broken.
Holy fuck!
If I find a hammerpoint, it's over.
It's fucking over.
Jesus.
That's scary.
That's actually scary.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Let's see.
Double hammerpoint.
Uh...
Alright.
Let's see.
Where's the...
Is that everything?
After that?
Or is there...
anything else I'm missing, guys?
Jeez.
That's fast.
That's fast if I have hammer...
Get the...
If I get shield out...
And then...
That shit is fast.
Ooh!
That shit is so fast.
Yeah, like I said, it's very beginner...
casual friendly, which is nice.
Ooh!
That damage!
I like that.
I like that damage.
Okay.
This is OGR9.
It feels like OGR9.
Wait.
Vantage has a passive?
That's disgusting.
This feels like OGR9 now.
Yeah.
That shit melts.
It does.
Oh my god!
That's so fast!
That's actually so fast.
Yeah.
The further you get...
The further you get, the sadder I become.
...
Alright!
Uh.
That's basically a shotgun now for me.
What was the Vantage change?
I didn't pay attention to Vantage.
Because I don't play her.
Alright, what did they change on her?
Let's see, refresh tactical... I don't even know if these were the same ones.
Like I don't... I don't even know.
I know like they adjusted the pattern.
What did they change?
What did they change on second ult hits deals more damage?
Okay, can we replace her?
She gets a shield scan regardless of scope?
Oh.
So...
I mean...
Two shot... second shot is 125.
Oh, okay.
Is it?
Oh, it is!
Oh, that shit's strong.
I don't even know what to play.
They made so many changes.
I don't know like what character to play.
Alright, let me see my frames real fast.
I think I'm... am I frame dropping?
I can't tell.
Uh, where is the perf...
Wait, my performance display is on.
Oh.
Sorry, I didn't see it.
Guys.
I'm a mess.
It was like, oh it is already on.
Alright, I don't know who to play.
I actually don't know.
They changed so many things.
I don't know.
I... I'm... I'm bad with decisions!
I'm so bad with decisions!
Alright, uh...
Trios revival?
Oh.
What's revival?
You made me down but you're not out.
When you're killed, you can automatically return to the fight.
Well, oh automatically.
But don't get...
Uh, automatic respawn.
Stop working late in the match.
Oh, so everybody just keeps coming back?
Over and over and over again?
Jesus Christ.
What?
You respawn at the end of a lockout time if at least one of your teammates is still standing.
The lockout timer can be decreased with smart plays.
Like surviving teammates doing damage on the ground.
Wait, why wait?
Players can pick up downed teammates even faster in revival mode.
What the fuck?
That shit's like...
That shit's like on steroids.
Like what?
That's like...
Uh...
Oh my god.
That's basically like that other game mode.
But they just pump like...
Five gallons of steroids on it.
Like...
Holy fuck.
Yeah.
Bro, that's not...
Yeah, that's some easy 4k.
Like...
Like what's the other...
The last...
That other game mode?
Three strikes.
This is literally three strikes.
But like...
What if we just remove all the strikes?
What if we just...
But what if we have like no strikes at all?
That's fucking crazy.
And like...
Nobody's gonna be down.
Like...
About the fast...
No, it is!
It's a fast res!
Down players even faster in revival mode.
Like three strikes over infinite strikes.
It does look...
It says fast res here.
Unless I'm reading it wrong.
I could be reading it wrong.
Because it says can pick up down teammates even faster in revival.
It's the end of the rat race.
Oh.
Hahaha.
Oh the time to revive gets progressively longer?
Alright, let's see.
Alright, I feel like since...
Since it's like...
Ultra lifeline.
I wanna see what the revive is.
If it's fast or not.
We'll see if the...
Fast.
If the revives are fast.
I'll be right back real quick before I queue.
Actually no, I can queue up while I...
I need to get tissues to blow my nose.
I'll be right back.
What is an instant?
I can't believe my game is already dying.
Hahaha.
I can't believe it.
Not an instant queue.
Hahaha.
Update literally came out three hours ago and I didn't get an instant queue.
Welcome back.
Hahaha.
Alright, here we go.
E-district.
I'm surprised they just were forced to do this mode.
I would just like to play it regular.
Not gonna lie.
I sort of just wanna play it regular game mode.
I don't wanna play three strikes on steroids.
Hahaha.
I feel like I'm gonna get so overwhelmed.
Alright, here we go.
Oh shit, invisible man.
He wants to do...
I'll do crypto after.
Yeah, I'm pretty sure it's to survive.
It's definitely for like survivability and stuff.
For sure.
Also, hold on.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I hate night maps.
Wooo.
Fucking hell, it's night time.
I don't know.
I don't like night maps because I'm fucking blind already.
Hahaha.
I'm already blind.
I need the light.
Hahaha.
Alright, let's see.
Cyberpunk density.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I fucking wear glasses.
Like I'm already like fucked up genetically.
When it comes to eyesight.
Hahaha.
Thank you for the gift.
Thank you.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna get like shit on just for the fact that I don't know where I am.
Like...
Hahaha.
I don't know where I am.
Where am I?
Okay.
Alright.
Oh.
Twelve enemies scanned.
They're over there.
What the fuck?
Is this... this map feels small when I look.
Isn't it like week one?
Oh guys, recycle!
Remember to recycle.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Hahaha.
Oh.
I played... Bro, okay.
I like it.
I told you guys.
They play tested this for a long time ago.
Hahaha.
Like... I don't remember.
It's been fucking months.
Hahaha.
Looking at the...
Um...
I want this just because it has the shield thing.
No, that doesn't have the shield thing.
Um...
I don't know what guns... Ooh.
Okay.
If I find another Mozamm.
It's on.
God, there's so much stuff.
There's so much stuff.
I'm getting overwhelmed already.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm in somebody's apartment.
Welcome to my crib.
This is where I'm moving, guys.
This is... Hahaha.
Alright.
Play with team.
Girl, the... Wait.
What the fuck?
He's the one that's not playing with team.
Bro, you can't just say play with team and run away from team.
Oh my god.
Where am I?
Hahaha.
Where... Where am I?
There's so many...
There's so many hiding places here.
Like, imagine all the rats here.
Oh my god.
There's parking?
What?
Hello.
Oh, he has the double door.
Oh my god.
Guys, you can park.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
Look at this.
This guy has like nice art.
Look, there's cars!
There's a taxi!
Uber hasn't been invented yet in this world!
That's fucked.
That's... Hahaha.
Hahaha.
Oh no!
They have a monopoly!
Oh my god.
Cars exist in the world of Apex.
Who would've thought?
Who would've fucking thought?
Uber was never...
They live in a dark era where Uber was not invented yet.
Hahaha.
They have everything but Ubers.
What the fuck is wrong with them?
Cars aren't even hovering!
They have to use wheels!
Wait, what?
I thought...
What happened to the hover cars?
Wait, where is this world?
There's no hover cars anywhere!
Hahaha.
There's wheels!
That's so fucked!
Hahaha.
That's so messed up.
I got the gun shield generator.
But I haven't found any...
Like, any of the LMGs.
Only Olympus had hover cars.
Olympus was clearly more developed.
Well, I would...
Oh.
Oh shit.
Oh, it's two teams.
Okay.
Ohhhh.
Cool down, increase, revive.
Alright, let's go.
I need to remember it's...
Oh my god!
Oh my god, they're...
He's in visible mode too.
Don't worry, I'm gonna do something dumb.
Like always.
Hahaha.
Anyway, I want loot.
Alright.
Oh my god, it's green now!
I don't like that.
Alright, I don't need any of this.
I'm like always...
I'm confused on what to loot.
I'm so...
I'm so confused on what to loot, not gonna lie.
Like...
I'm so overwhelmed with all the stuff they have.
So it's like, what do I even loot?
Alright, let's go.
Guys, as long as one of you lives, that's all that matters.
Wow!
I needed that actually.
Nice.
Alright, let's go.
Trust your instinct.
Yeah, but what if my instinct is wrong?
Oh shit!
Hello.
I'm gonna throw you.
Just cause I can.
Alright.
He doesn't know.
He doesn't fucking know.
Wait, where's the other one?
Haha, no fear!
Wait.
They're spawning?
Oh, you don't thirst them.
I guess I shouldn't have rethirsted them.
That's bad.
We should have kept them down.
No!
Inspect the Mozamb?
Okay.
What is it?
What am I doing?
What am I...
Oh, okay!
Wow!
Bro, I'm fucking playing soccer!
Alright, let's see.
I need an LMG for my shield generator.
Let's see.
We need an LMG.
Bro, look at those kicks though.
There's three other squads?
I'm so lost.
Hey, we can get some fucking coke.
Look at these.
What is this?
Oh, I'm in Japan.
Guys, I take back everything I said about like how they don't have hover cars.
Like, wheels are just so much better, guys.
Wheels are... wheels are...
Hahaha!
Guys, I take it back.
I didn't mean it.
Guys, this is very developed.
This is a very developed place.
They don't need a float.
They don't need a float, guys.
Hahaha!
Oh, there we go.
Finally, I have an SMG.
Or LMG.
Hahaha!
Alright, we can get this.
Wheels are like...
Hovering?
Like, why would I need a hover when wheels are just faster?
Where do I go?
Like...
Where do I...
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, floating is so fun.
I'm fucking stupid.
Hahaha!
What advantages does it actually give anyway?
What about this?
Grub.
Oh, that's why there's vending machines everywhere!
Big grub!
Alright.
Let's see...
Oh my god.
My inventory is a fucking mess.
Because I'm so overwhelmed on like...
I mean, look at all these public transports!
Where are the civilians though?
Like...
Floating is so overrated.
Exactly.
It really is.
Alright, we have like...
I feel like Evo Shield definitely takes a little bit harder to...
Everybody is alive, yet there's nobody!
Like...
Where is anybody in this world?
How is everybody alive, but we've only found two teams?
The Prowlers?
What the fuck?
There's a lot of set dressing.
Not gonna lie though!
I think this...
Alright.
If... and somebody has like a...
I wanna know for those who have like less...
Um...
Less like bulky PCs...
How it does with your PC.
Because I...
This feels like this will eat up a lot of...
This feels like it eats up a lot.
Hahaha!
Of resources.
Not gonna lie.
It's fine for you?
Okay.
That's good!
Because it feels like there's a lot going on when it comes to like...
Stuff around the world.
There's a lot of stuff.
There's like flowers too!
There's an emergency alert!
This is not a drill!
Lore!
No one really cares about the lore in this game though.
Not gonna lie.
Monkey man?
No.
We must kill monkey man.
I can at least...
Yeah I feel like... even I'm experiencing...
Like...
I don't know if it's noticeable for you guys...
But like even I feel a little bit like...
Some small frame drops...
When I look at certain places.
Hahaha!
I could feel like a little bit of frame dropping.
I don't know if it's noticeable to you guys.
Hahaha!
But like some areas I look at and I'm like...
Wooohooo!
I see...
Yeah!
I can see it on my frame count!
Oh!
There's people here.
Where do we fight?
I guess we could fight the people next to us.
I think it's frame stu...
Yeah!
There's like a slight frame stutter.
Just a small one.
It is very annoying.
Wait!
What if I...
Uhhhh...
I do not need all these.
Alright, I'm heating it up.
Let's go!
Are you guys scared of pussies?
I can't climb up.
There's like people here too.
Oh!
Okay.
I was trying to figure out how to get up here better.
Alright!
Where are they?
Where?
Hahaha!
It's right in the fucking shield.
No!
He's literally one!
Wait!
No, don't thirst me!
No!
Guys!
Yes!
Oh shit!
Wait, there's another squad.
Oh no.
Oh god.
Okay.
I was too...
That's fucking right.
Wait, is that another squad?
Woo!
Oh!
Get over here!
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's see.
Nice.
Alright.
Don't worry!
Crypto, I got you bro!
Nice.
Alright.
We're fine.
I panicked a little cause...
Uh...
Whoa!
I panicked a little because like I...
I didn't know what I was doing.
It's been a while.
I've been playing Overwatch.
I've been playing Overwatch so I panicked a little bit.
No!
I forgot!
Does it register?
Before I open it?
Alright.
We'll find out.
Well, we gotta wait then.
We gotta wait!
Alright.
Hey, we have a package there.
I'm gonna look for it.
Nothing bad's gonna happen.
Oh no!
He's on the grid!
He's back on the grid!
Oh shit!
Goodbye.
I'm done playing with you.
I'm fucking done playing with you.
Okay, we need like an actual Thermite though.
Over here?
Oh, they're over there.
Alright.
Let's go.
Let's see.
Ugh!
Alright.
Wait, why did you EMP so far?
I can't reach that!
What's the red thing though?
Woah!
Alright.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
I wish I have...
I do wish I have...
Uh...
I wish I do have like a Thermite though.
Wait!
That could've been my Thermite!
I'm like, I'm gonna look over there.
Oh my gosh, I didn't even realize.
Oh!
From where though?
Joke's on you, I was just about to bat.
Oh no, he's off the grid.
So I don't know where he is.
He's off the grid!
Okay.
I'm gonna ignore...
I'm not gonna thirst him because of the fact that...
Okay, he thirsted him.
Okay, so uh...
I need his loot though.
I need like his...
I need...
I'd rather go with 3x.
I feel more confident in 3x for this.
Uhhhh...
Alright.
Any Thermites?
Any Thermites in town?
Nope.
Okay.
Three other squads?
Where though?
Someone's off the grid though.
There's caustic gases.
Woah!
That's right.
Get down from here.
Fucking idiot.
That's fucking right.
Never shoot me again.
Three squads now.
Why are they not in zone?
Where?
Woah!
Sir, are you okay?
Don't worry, I got you!
I fucking got you!
Where are they?
Get off the grid, Crypto!
Get off the grid!
They're gonna find you!
You didn't burn your fingerprints off!
Oh!
Hear them.
I literally hear them right on top of me.
Is that ours?
What the fuck?
Wait, there's a guy right here.
Sorry!
I should not have shot that guy.
I was just like, what is he doing in there?
Alright.
Oh, they're falling off.
I hate it.
Oh shit!
I fucked up!
I didn't realize they were up there.
Alright.
This is dumb.
Bro, this is fucking quick play!
I mean...
Sorry.
Mine is on full on Overwatch mode right now.
Fucking hell.
Alright, we're gonna put this in the...
I'm gonna put this up there.
Don't worry.
Everything is fine.
We have this cover.
Okay!
Everything is so fine.
Don't...
I feel so safe here.
Yippee!
Please!
My god!
Chill!
I have it thrown in my...
I don't wanna use it yet.
Everybody is like...
Not chill right now!
Guys!
Please!
Chill a little bit!
Just a tiny bit guys!
Rink!
Rink reset!
Come on guys!
Go play Rink!
Have fun!
Bro, they're all like on high ground?
Where the fuck is that?
Where is here?
Bro!
Bro, they're like doing corners and stuff too.
Where is that over there?
Where is this?
Oh my god!
I wanna know where that is.
On the map.
It doesn't...
It literally doesn't tell you where that is.
Okay.
Please!
I just wanna know!
I wanna know exactly where that is!
I don't wanna ping people!
I just wanted to know where that is!
Okay.
I'll charge it up now.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
I do something really stupid.
If I climb here.
To be fair, I can look up from here too.
Really?
What the fuck?
Oh no, I'm fucked up.
I didn't see... I didn't realize he was gonna go up there.
Alright.
This is fucked up, man.
This is actually so fucked up, guys.
This is actually...
This is so fucked up.
I revved too late.
I revved too early.
Oh, nice!
Okay, I definitely revved too early though.
He ulted too early too.
Oh.
Where?
Okay.
There.
Oh my god, come on, ping me.
That's fucking right.
You have to heal now, bitch.
That's right, bitch!
I don't have third might anymore.
I definitely third mighted too early.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Bro, you're crazy.
Okay, this is bad for me.
This is bad.
Alright, let's go in!
Oh.
That sucks for me, that's for sure.
Oh, that sucks for me, that's for sure.
Bro, fuck you though!
Fuck you for that bulls For your high ground bullshit!
BITCH!
NOOOOOO!
YOU'RE STUPID HIGHGROUND!
Am I alive?
That's a good question.
Fuck you and your high ground bullshit!
You know what?
I think I hate this meta.
I think...
You know what?
I think this meta is pretty fucking dumb.
I got fucking high ground.
It's so hard.
God damn it.
Let's see.
I'm gonna make sure...
Let's see...
Let's see if I can fix my...
What if I can fix my...
uh...
What's the word?
Am I okay?
I'm on 280.
I just wanna make sure I'm on 280 hertz.
God.
This map is taking so much of my fucking frames.
Alright.
Uhhhh...
That was the first game.
Yeah.
From that first game, I realized what the meta was gonna be.
Like...
I realized!
From...
From that first game alone...
It made me realize what this meta was gonna be like.
...
Uh...
Let's see.
Trying to figure out...
Uh...
...
Trying to figure out what to play.
That fucking Caustic buff though is pretty nuts.
I guess we'll try Crypto and be off the grid.
Thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Alright, let me see my settings.
Jesus Christ, is everything on low?
Okay, everything is on low, but Jesus Christ!
That shit was like...
This map...
It's like...
What map was it that used to cause this issue?
There was a specific map that used to do this before.
Was it...
Was it Broken Moon?
No, I can't... It was Broken Moon!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This felt like Broken Moon on launch.
This felt... You know like, when Broken Moon first launched and it was like...
Was it Storm Point?
Alright, but... What?
Who the fuck said that?
It was a map on launch?
Fucking...
I will... I will... I will...
Fuck.
Yeah.
Just a fan.
I thought that was like... Who the fuck...
Who the fuck said that?
Oh my god!
This... This is how little I played Crypto.
I literally have...
What the...
What the fuck?
What is going on?
Oh my god.
Um... Fuck!
I lost my train of thought!
Check the Twitch?
Bro, that's a fake fucking fan right there.
I checked the Twitch, bro!
Oh my god!
Wait, that's the real one!
I won't let you down!
Bro...
I think he's gonna let me down.
That's what they all say.
That's what they all fucking say.
Hehehehehehe.
Alright.
No, this feels like one of those map... This doesn't feel as optimized as I like.
Because... Oh my god.
I get like, frame stutters a little.
I might have to lower my frames or something.
This shit, it sucks.
Oh, I hear them.
Whoa!
I hear them above me!
This might be where I die.
Hehehehe.
Oh.
This might be where I die.
Oh, it's okay.
He's more scared of me than I am.
Hahahaha!
That's good.
He's scared of me because I was like, oh, I whiffed.
Hahaha!
I'm glad.
Thank god.
I love it when they're scared and I'm like, ooh.
Ooh!
Oh!
That frame stutter!
Whoa!
Ah, it was frame stuttering!
It's not fair!
I was literally frame stuttering!
Where's the door?
Where's the stairs?
Where the fuck are the stairs?
Okay.
What the fuck?
I'm like, so confused!
Oh!
Okay.
Woah.
Haha!
Okay.
Okay, well...
Okay, I'm alive.
Okay.
Alright.
Whoa!
It's okay, my teammates are coming back!
No!
Who's this bitch?
It's okay, my teammates.
Do they have guns when they come in?
They do!
It's alright.
As long as they live in 17 seconds...
I told you guys.
Anytime someone always goes like, I'll never let you down.
They always let me down.
You have to go in with very low expectations.
I knew that was gonna happen.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna land away from them.
So I can actually get stuff.
If they die, they'll just respawn anyway.
It's literally... there's no strikes.
Can't play without aim assist.
That's a good name!
Right there!
That is such a good name.
I can't find a second Mozamm.
At all.
Alright, they'll be fine.
I'm just gonna loot.
They'll be fine.
I believe in my team!
He literally said like...
He won't let me down, right?
I believe in him.
Maybe I should try the Spitfire.
I wanna try the Spitfire.
Oh!
There's a Rev.
Whoa!
Two squads near by?
Guys, I don't have...
How did she get purple?
What did she...
What the fuck?
Okay.
Wait, he came back?
Oh!
Cause he got...
It's the fucking... I forgot.
The respawn on...
I swear... Okay, thank god he wasn't the asshole that did the finisher.
It's okay!
14 more seconds!
Live!
Oh my god.
There's so many people.
But when does it end?
What zone does it end?
It's Zonio.
Yay!
We're back!
Yippee!
33 seconds now!
It's okay!
We're back!
Yippee!
Hahaha!
Round 3!
I will never be able to use my...
Or any of my abilities at this rate!
The only fun part about crypto are the upgrades!
I'm scared!
Okay.
All right.
I have one squad, but where?
Oh, there.
Oh, the range is shorter.
Wait, is the range shorter?
It's like over here somewhere.
Where are they?
I'll never be able to fucking... Oh, they're over there.
I'll never be able to get an upgrade or use my ult at this rate.
Like, I don't know.
I'm not off the grid yet!
They still have my... The government still has my information!
Oh my god.
I'm so close to a second Evo.
And then I can be off the grid.
We're almost there, guys.
I just need to hit 50.
Alright, this is it.
I'm gonna do it.
Watch this.
Okay.
Guys, I'm lagging.
Oh shit, off the grid!
Let's go!
I can do this!
I'm not being afraid!
Let's go!
Guys, please.
I'm off the grid, please, guys.
I'm off the grid.
Oh wait.
Oh, there's a Mirage?
Wait, did they buff Mirage or something?
Where is it?
That's a Mirage clone, you idiots!
Guys, just give me... I need 78% and I can be off the grid again.
Oh no.
JK, off the grid!
They won't know.
Where could I be?
I'm invisible!
How would they know?
How could they know?
They'll never know.
Exactly.
If I'm off the grid, they'll never know.
Yeah!
Okay, I'm risking this just because I want to...
Oh my god, really?
Oh god.
They won't know.
Off the grid time!
How would they know?
How...
If I save, I get a chance!
How would they know?
Please don't shoot me.
Please.
They'll never know.
I really need a heal.
I really really need a heal.
But like this is not a good place to be right now.
It's not.
I don't feel safe.
I don't.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
Oh I don't have shields.
I don't have.
Oh ho ho.
Guys we gotta fly.
I can't get off the grid anymore guys.
We gotta leave.
Oh my god.
Shoot my buddy.
Shoot him.
It's pretty.
I'm not safe anymore guys.
I like how I can like stop fighting.
In the middle.
In the middle of the fight.
Just cause I'm off the grid.
That's so fucking dumb.
That's actually so dumb.
I literally...
I can just exist in the middle of the fight.
It's so stupid.
I love it.
I actually love it.
You just disappeared.
They can't kill me if I'm invisible.
It's impossible.
This is great.
I think I actually like crypto.
Just cause it's so fucking stupid.
Gamers don't look up exactly.
Gamers don't look up.
Oh I hear fights here.
I hear a fight over there.
What do I do for the second upgrade?
I guess I'll do... I guess I can... Oh the speed so my drone can live longer.
That makes sense.
There's like people over there.
I have zero attachments throughout this entire fight.
But...
Woooo!
It's time.
They won't know.
They won't know!
How would they know?
Throw it out.
I'm literally so safe.
Okay I'm gonna wait until... I'm gonna wait until like...
Does it look up?
It doesn't look up.
No no no.
Nope.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
Everything is a-okay.
Hey guys.
Just to fuck with people.
Weeow!
Goodbye.
Oh.
Hahaha!
Goodbye guys.
Is it safe?
Are we safe?
Okay.
We're safe.
Alright.
My job here is done.
Hahaha!
But you didn't do anything.
Exactly.
Hahaha!
Alright.
Let's see.
Woo!
Nice.
I need that.
I need this.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Off the grid.
Do not worry.
Everything is fine.
Enemy landed close to me.
Enemy?
It landed where?
Where is it?
No?
Oh there.
No.
You can't.
Don't destroy it.
Don't worry.
We'll be fine.
Where am I?
Hahaha!
Don't worry.
I...
Hahaha!
Wait.
Where are they?
Oh there they are.
There they are.
They're over here.
Oh no no.
Don't shoot my drone.
How else will I live?
Oh shit.
Guys we have to go.
Hahaha.
Wooow.
No, no, no.
Off the grid.
Oh shit.
No.
Hahahahah.
It almost worked though.
Guys it almost worked.
Hahahahaha.
Hey guys.
I said it almost worked.
That was so smart though!
That was so smart!
Oh my god!
Okay!
That was the smartest shit I ever did!
So... I just didn't expect the second guy.
The second guy came out of nowhere!
I got my one!
I
told you!
This is how it went!
Crypto is fun!
I should really choose Crypto!
I never... They never expect the second guy!
I've never expected the second guy!
I got the outplay though!
That fucking outplay was so good!
No, it's just the Gibby!
The goddamn Gibby!
I keep everything!
This is like three strikes, but on steroids.
Okay.
Let's see.
Up high ground I go!
Don't worry guys!
They'll never know!
Shit!
Okay, sorry!
They'll never know!
Because I want to scan this!
Nice!
Wow!
That's a lot!
Holy shit!
Okay, I'll get the speed.
They'll never know!
How would they know?
That's a lot of people, not gonna lie.
Can I scan it again?
No, not again.
Alright, we're gonna put this here.
We're gonna put this guy here.
Off the grid.
Alright.
I'm gonna stay here.
I don't want to... I don't want to deal with...
Aww!
Doesn't help that I have like barely any attachments!
It does not help at all!
Wait, our guy needs help.
What the fuck?
Wait, that's a Gibby!
That fucker!
That's the guy that did the finisher too, I'm pretty sure.
Oh, it's alright.
I'm safe here in my hidey hole.
Where is he?
Alright.
Come on!
Get out of that shield!
Wait, where's his buddy?
Alright, we gotta go back up.
Alright.
I have zero attachments for anything.
Woah!
Consequences of my own actions.
If I look at a certain direction with like all that shit all over my screen...
I can't see it.
My frame drops by like fucking 60 or some shit.
Okay.
Oh no, wait, we have to go to the other side.
Wait, this is not good.
Wait a minute, we have to cross.
Wait a... guys, we're a little fucked here.
Um...
How do I get there?
How do I...
How... how do I get there?
Um...
Alright.
So that's them running now.
They're running over here now.
Okay, we gotta figure out... I'm gonna hack this door.
Okay, and then... I open some doors.
Okay, I'm gonna be here.
They won't know.
How would they know?
Alright, they all rotated so we should be good now.
Nice.
Alright, alright, let's go, let's go.
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry, I'm running in!
But
nothing!
Oh no, wait a minute.
Oh no.
Wait.
Why are they high ground?
It's not fair.
Oh no...
What?!
He shot from where?!
I knew I should've been off the grid.
I should've never came back into the grid.
I should've...
I should've never...
I fucking knew it!
Never come back from the grid!
I'm sorry, we failed you!
Never come back from...
I fucking knew it!
I never listened to my teammates.
Never listen to your teammates and never come back from the grid.
That...
That's just...
I can't believe it.
I'm like...
It's always high ground!
They said they got the line!
The grid...
The government has my social security number now!
Look what they did!
What the fuck?
I can't believe it!
From this game, I have learned to never trust any of my teammates ever again.
That's what...
From that game alone!
I have learned...
Teammates never...
Teammates do not matter to me.
Fuuup...
I think I like crypto.
Not gonna lie.
Crypto has been...
Really fun!
Crypto has been really fun so far.
I've been really enjoying it.
Time for number 3...
I think... I don't know what...
I think like... I don't know if crypto is gonna be good in an actual scenario.
Like if I'm not fucking around.
I feel like crypto might be like really really good if I wasn't fucking around a lot, but like I'm fucking around.
I'm fucking around.
I'm like fucking juking people with the invisibility.
I'm literally... I'm literally just going invisible in front of people.
That outplay was so good though.
I just didn't expect the second guy.
If there was no second guy, that would have been such a good outplay.
Because I knew they were behind me.
Now you see me, now you don't.
Heh heh heh heh heh heh heh.
All right, give me a sec.
I tabbed out.
All right, here we go.
The magician they call her.
Wee-oooh!
Oh!
Wait, that's sick.
I didn't realize I had that.
This is how little I play crypto.
Doki likes crypto now.
Next thing you're telling me she's making her own Doki coin.
Oh!
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, let's see.
This... this has a lot of stuff.
The moment my frame starts dropping, I look at my surrounding and I'm like, yeah, that makes sense.
Yeah, this...
Yeah.
All right, let's see.
Oh!
My gosh, it's a market!
it's a food market!
Nice.
That's cute Yeah, there is a loss.
I don't know if it's just me, or if anybody else is having the same issue right now.
But it is a little annoying.
But like, you know... It's...
It was, like... It was either a broken moon or a storm point.
Oh, it was!
It was a storm point, yeah.
Storm point was like this on lost moon.
And launch too.
I remember.
Storm Point was like this on launch.
It was Storm Point.
Where like, there was too much grass.
And the foliage was really pretty and everything.
But it was fucking killing my frames.
Yeah, but the drop is noticeable.
It's like, because I'm really used to a specific amount of frames.
I could lock it.
I'm gonna see if I can lock my frames.
I usually lock it at a specific amount.
But I don't know if it's... if I have it...
I don't remember what I used to lock it in.
I don't know if it is locked right now.
That's the thing.
I don't think it is.
It feels weird.
Alright, let's check.
Let's check if there's people here.
Yeah, it's not nice.
It definitely is not.
There is...
I don't remember.
There's like a specific frame you frame.
That you should lock for Apex.
But I'm not sure if I have it on this PC.
Alright.
I have a beefy PC though.
Draft point.
There's like people there.
Nice.
Where am I?
I'm like, nice.
But also, where am I?
You got this.
I'm like, I'm like, I'm like.
Oh shit.
It's time.
It's fucking time.
Is it 240?
Am I?
I think I have it locked at...
No, I don't.
Okay.
I'm going to lock it 240 and see if it helps.
I know it was like, um, like a specific number.
Like, was it 249 or something?
I don't remember.
It's been a while since I looked at my frame lock on Steam.
All right.
It's time.
Oh, I should recall it.
Re-calling.
All right.
Where are they?
I must fight.
I must fight, but also like, not really.
Oh, they used to be.
Oh yeah, 189.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I remember because like, like, some of my pro friends, I don't know who, but one of my pro friends was like, yeah, you should lock at this because Apex can end up doing Apex can only run at this amount, so it doesn't matter.
Or something.
I remember, they were like, Apex can only run at this specific amount of frames, so you have to lock it.
Like, it doesn't matter if you lock it like...
If your PC monitor can handle big higher frames, Apex itself can only run this amount.
Sorry.
Goodbye.
Bloodhound, good luck.
Good luck.
Good luck, everybody.
I will help.
Now.
See, I contributed!
Says... says Wins.
I can make.
I helped, what do you mean?
Off the grid.
Don't worry.
I burned my Social Security card this time.
That was my mistake last time.
I thought I needed..
I thought I needed credit.
But who needs credit?
I don't need credit.
This time.
We'll be fine now.
What do you mean I'm doing so well?
I'm off the grid.
I don't know what else you want me to...
Say it's a crypto player that's on the grid.
All right, I'm gonna grab that purple light mag though.
Exactly!
Who needs credit when you have your crypto?
Besides, I did get that ult in.
That was a good ult.
Our guy hasn't even healed his shields yet.
Yeah, we should be able to...
Should be able to grab like uh...
The scan there.
The squad in this direction?
Definitely need shields.
Whoa!
All right, I should use more of the new guns but like I'm not.
All right.
Oh wait, I forgot!
He's Bloodhound.
Whoa!
That's a lot of people fighting there.
That's a lot of people.
What are these green things?
Is it like potential end zones?
Or like teams?
Potential teams there.
All right, let's see.
Whoa!
Oh, it's so far.
There's two squads near us.
Oh!
There's a crypto!
Oh no!
He's gonna see me!
Get away!
No!
He's gonna see me!
He's gonna see me right there!
He's gonna...
No, I'm like... He's gonna see this one dot crypto right here!
That's fucking right.
Wee-oh!
Get better aim, bitch.
Don't look up.
Don't look up though.
I need to be on the grid.
Don't... I need to be...
Don't look up, please!
Don't look up!
Okay, there we go.
Okay.
I don't think they can shoot that.
I think I got it perfectly.
Okay.
This is it.
Whoa!
How did he know?!
Oh, shit!
Oh!
How did he know?!
Hehehe!
Can't go again!
He can't know I'm here.
He can't know I stayed there.
He can't know I stayed here?
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
Alright.
Sorry, team.
I'll stay alive because I'm...
Don't worry, team.
Hahaha!
Don't worry!
There we go!
I did my job!
I did my part.
Guys, I 100% did my part there.
Like, team, I did my part.
They got third-partied!
Guys, they literally got third-partied.
Like, what do you want from me?
They got third-partied!
There was nothing I could do!
Hahaha!
There's really nothing.
We could have all died.
But because I did my part, nobody died.
How do you get there?
Like...
How?
Oh, this way.
I might die from the lack of heals though.
I actually don't have heals.
Oh, no.
Don't tell me we all need health.
Hahaha!
Oh, I like that though.
No!
I'm gonna die from this!
None of us has HP!
No!
Whoa!
Hey, guys.
We have a heal drone.
Oh, thank god.
Oh, we live just a little longer.
Okay, I'm gonna put a redeploy on that side.
Okay.
I have a redeploy.
Am I the only one with a redeploy?
I am.
Alright, this is our only hope to live, guys.
Okay.
Uh...
Let's go.
Let's do this.
Okay, I don't know if I'm gonna live all the way, but like, it's the effort.
Meow!
I'm gonna die in the air.
I'm 100% gonna die.
Unless...
Oh!
Woo!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Let me heal up first so I can feel a little safer.
I...
Alright.
Oh, I hear people.
Oh, no.
No.
No, he's on the grid!
No!
Oh, god.
Please.
Oh, my god.
I have nothing.
Oh, no.
There's over there.
They're over there.
No!
You bitch!
Please!
We have to go to zone!
No!
My...
bitches!
Oh, god.
I can't live here.
Okay.
No.
Lifeline, you just... Lifeline just has to live like seven seconds.
Two.
One.
Yes!
Lifeline!
Live forever!
Yes!
That's all I wanted.
We can die now.
We can die in peace.
The Lifeline lived for us.
We can...
We can die in peace now.
I might as well be dead so I can regen my HP.
I might as well.
Okay.
But, like, what if...
Shit!
The grid!
I just... I just wanted to get off the grid!
Oh, no.
It's up to me.
Please, live three...
Two... One...
Zero...
Oh, my god!
I'm so close!
We... We really needed one more second.
Bro!
Okay.
Alright.
We have a little special guest joining us.
As per tradition.
I also need to cap my frames real fast.
Let me...
As per tradition.
Every season launch.
Except for one, sadly.
We always had one person that would join us.
And I'm not sure if it's a good thing or not.
But, I'm sure that So, we have a little And we have a little Oh, yeah.
Have you tried crypto?
That shit's... I'm a crypto man.
I enjoyed it.
I was playing him.
I was going off the grid.
Though... His shit is very loud, though.
Is it?
I was not paying attention.
As long as your drone isn't near you.
As long as your drone is not near you, it's fine.
I feel like...
Oh, my god!
I didn't cap my frames.
That makes so much more sense now.
My launch options.
Yeah.
190?
No, there's like a specific...
I think they fixed it, though.
Launch options.
Guys, what's the launch options that you do for Apex?
Again?
I don't remember.
Because this PC doesn't have it.
Okay, I'm gonna up the engine a little bit.
Guys, what are the Apex launch options that you put?
Uh...
Guys, give me the like line.
The line code.
Not the frame number.
The command line.
Command line.
Yeah, the command line.
I feel like there's more, is it?
Was it just the FPS or was it more stuff?
I don't remember.
Probably.
I'll do 240 for now.
Let's see if that works.
Alright.
Oh, my god.
That makes more sense now.
I did not have my frames capped.
Alright, let's see if this is better.
You do that?
Yeah.
That's... Honestly?
What?
You don't?
I don't.
Should I?
Yeah.
I used to like limit it to 190.
Yeah, optimize your game more.
Like 190.
What do you mean?
Hold on, let me just...
Let's see this bullshit 3.
You have to do FPS max something something.
Oh, they have a new like respawn.
Like Apex Legends respawn thingy.
Guys, is Tengen better or should I up him more?
I like the new season.
I love crypto.
Crypto is so fun to play.
How do you enjoy crypto?
That's the thing.
Off the grid?
I don't see you as a crypto player.
I'm not doing it to like kill people.
I'm doing it to fuck around.
So I would knock somebody and then I go off the grid in front of them.
But with the off the grid, I feel like I can make some plays.
Yeah, yeah.
I run full corner and just...
pull up my drone and just...
I'm gone.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The funniest one is that I was getting chased but the zone was also pushing in.
And then like I went off the grid while I was in the zone and a team was coming behind me and then they ran past me and then I came back in the grid and shot them in the back.
But then like I didn't see the second guy!
And then the second guy killed me.
I didn't see the second guy.
Alright, invite me.
I'll play on your server.
My server?
Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
Guys.
Who else should I play?
With the new characters.
Are we playing rank?
No, we're not fucking playing rank.
We're gonna play Trios Revival.
Fucking Revival.
This...
This new map is kind of confusing me.
Like I swear.
I don't know.
Tempo is like go in the tree, go off the grid, win rank game.
We're not...
There's no trees in fucking Chalkway!
What do you mean?
It's buildings!
There's apartments!
It's Angel City.
What's up?
Tengen a bit more.
Is it better now?
I haven't seen any Vantage players.
Chat's telling me to play Vantage but I literally have not seen any Vantage players.
Did they change Vantage?
Yeah, they made it her second shot is more buff and you don't have to look at Echo anymore to go to places.
That's nice.
But I've not seen any Vantage players.
It's mostly Crypto and Watson that I see a lot.
To be fair, this is my fourth game today.
Right.
I've played like three already.
Alright, invite me whenever.
Don't touch any FPS and like...
Damn.
I've been playing Overwatch.
You have?
Oh shit.
I was in the firing range.
I thought it shows up when you're in the firing range.
Does it?
Oh, Rampart.
I still love Rampart.
Yeah.
I'm here.
I'm gonna play Rampart.
You can do Crypto.
I'll do Rampart.
Sure.
The fuck?
I can't change.
Oh my god.
I love launch day bugs.
Yeah.
I love it.
I love it when launch day bugs are like this.
Alright.
Let's try out Rampart.
What games have you been playing, Tenjin?
I'll be honest.
GTA RP.
You've been doing GTA RP?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
In Indonesia?
Yeah, the Indonesian side of the servers basically.
I am actually enjoying it.
And I have not touched FPS.
GTA RP has been like a big thing back in like NA times.
I know.
Like a couple years back.
It's funny that it hit Asia like last year.
I think that's funny.
It's not exactly last year.
It's been there for quite a while.
Yeah, but like the... Because in Asia, the most popular one is still the GTA San Andreas role-playing stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, but like it got like more popular.
Like the...
Yeah.
It like blew up last year.
People... It's more accessible now, basically, to play GTA 5.
So... Yeah.
Yeah.
Alright.
Here we go.
I can't wait to see your outplays.
Honestly, I haven't even like tried the invisible yet.
You haven't tried?
Wait, you haven't done the invisibility?
What have you been doing?
I haven't.
I've been grabbing the other stuff and showed it like sick crypto plays.
What?
You haven't been doing like the main part?
Oh, I'm at a pool.
That's funny.
Emily, you haven't been doing the main...
I have not.
Oh my god.
I can...
What ping is this?
Oh, 2-1.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well, what do you think about the health bar, though?
Health bar?
I don't like it that much, to be fair.
What the fuck?
Yeah, me neither.
Like the highlight is nice, but like...
Guys.
Hey, guys.
I have a lifeline on me.
I had a lifeline.
And I had a winning man.
Oh.
He's over here.
Tension.
Beat him up.
I cracked him twice already.
Whoa.
I'll just res you.
Yeah, just res me.
It's fast.
No, it's not fast.
I got light.
I thought it was fast too, but it's not.
It's pretty slow, not gonna lie.
Oh my god, you're already off the grid.
I am.
Can I scan it again?
Oh wait.
Guys.
I don't think I was... He's very low.
He's super low.
Someone get this wingman off my body.
Holy shit, he's super low.
Okay.
Bro, you have a wingman.
You should have won that.
What do you mean?
I played 200 ping wingman.
I was literally in NA.
I was in NA.
I forgot where you live sometimes.
What do you mean you forget where I live?
Someone get this.
Okay, I'm gonna throw this wingman.
You take the wingman.
I should not.
I spent too long off the grid.
I spent too long being invisible.
Also like, is this a bad time to tell you?
This might be my third time playing Rampart.
In my life.
Ever since Rampart came out.
I actually have not seen you play any other legends.
Yeah, I think this is a bad time to tell you that.
And they're over here.
Woah, what the fuck?
Oh, please.
What the fuck?
Where did she come from?
Where did this girl came from?
Okay, so there is the lifeline right here.
That I did not hear.
I swear to god.
I swear.
I will come back and fucking kill you.
I will come back and kill you.
Please do not kill this lifeline.
I swear to god.
I need to kill her myself.
Come on, fight your demons.
Oh, I see.
I see you.
I'm coming back just for the lifeline.
I need a second gun though.
That's all I need.
I'm still...
Oh, there they are.
Where are they?
Here?
Let the lifeline live.
I need...
The lifeline has to live.
Oh my god.
Okay, I fucked up.
Already.
Okay.
Wait, where are they?
I'm literally fighting both of them.
No, the lifeline has to live.
Oh, the lifeline is...
The lifeline is alive.
Somewhere.
The lifeline!
You have to let me get the lifeline.
That's all I want.
The lifeline has to live.
That should be the lifeline.
Where are you, lifeline?
Where is she?
Where the fuck is she?
Where?
Where is she?
Is she inside?
Is she...
I swear I haven't even gotten like a fucking...
Where the fuck is she?
She has high ground!
This bitch!
I don't have shields.
Do you have shields?
I do, I do, I do.
I don't have shields, this fucker.
She's like actually the bane of my existence right now.
I don't even have an attachment.
Ooh, a golden...
Yeah, you know what?
This works.
Yeah, dude, fuck this bitch!
There, fight him.
Where is she?
Oh, I think someone fell.
Lifeline zombie!
Lifeline zombie, where is she?
Where is she?
Where'd she go?
Where did she go?
Oh, she's right here.
Let her respawn!
Don't kill this team!
Fully let her respawn!
That's all I want.
Where is she?
I want the lifeline to come back.
I need her to come back.
I need her.
After today.
Let her come respawn.
What the fuck do I want?
Reduce all cooldown?
Okay.
Why not?
Where did she go?
Where are they?
I don't know.
I need... I need... fucking... what's her name?
That extra shield in the save zone is nice though.
Yeah, that is nice.
Where is she?
Where's the lifeline?
I need her to keep respawning two more times.
Before I...
She craves violence.
Where did they go?
Did they run?
Did they fucking run?
Those pussies!
Quiet.
I can't believe they actually ran.
Holy fuck.
It's been all quiet so yeah they might be running.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe those cowards!
It's actually fucked up.
It's so fucked up.
Alright.
We gotta go find them.
We have...
It's not over yet.
It's not over.
It's far from over.
They got me at a bad time while I was trying to adjust to your ping.
I'm not gonna...
But it doesn't reach like six shields.
It's only like five.
Yeah.
Okay so does it feel like the map isn't optimized or is just my end?
Um...
I don't know.
Cause like...
I just upgraded my graphics card so I wouldn't know.
Yeah I'm on M40 but like...
I think I might just need...
I might need more RAM too cause like I noticed like ever since I swapped my CPU...
Yeah it's 170.
When I swapped my CPU and motherboard my RAM usage got like insane.
So I don't know.
I don't know if it's like...
Has a deal with also my CPU and also my motherboard.
No I know that lifeline is still alive.
I know you're still fucking alive.
Is that you?
Oh shit!
Why?
Every time.
Every time I wanna get into a different fight.
This is not fair.
They're over there.
To your left.
I'm buggin'.
Building walls.
Funny buggin'.
I'm building walls.
Where are they?
Yo they're so far!
They're super far.
Yeah they're so far but they're being little bitches!
What the fuck?
They're not...
Somebody's on me.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Multiple of them.
I need help.
Sure.
Nevermind.
They destroyed my drone.
I'll get to you.
I hope so.
Cause they're literally on me.
Miss didn't see me?
Oh.
Hahaha!
Haha!
Oh our Watson was not...
I got you.
Uh...
Where is he?
Woah!
What the fuck kind of movement tech are you watching?
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Where did he come from?
Wait actually where is he?
Wait that's a different guy!
That's a different guy homie.
Hello.
I'm fighting another guy.
I'm batting.
It's okay our Watson's coming back soon.
I'm dead.
Oh it's okay our Watson's gonna clutch this up.
At being alive.
Jesus Christ.
Fight me bro fight me.
I'm just gonna bleed out.
That's a good idea.
No!
I got pinged!
Are you fucking...
I hit two!
It's okay.
Camila please!
Don't land on them I swear to god!
23 seconds.
Just leave them.
I'm in second ping.
20 seconds.
It's enough!
It's enough time!
Please!
Don't go in there!
I beg of you!
Don't even fight this!
Just like calm down.
I got pinged.
I got pinged so high.
Go park!
Park your car!
Go park your car!
Alright I need...
Yeah this map is like overly complex as shit.
Oh yeah no 100%.
Like 180 FPS.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Like there's a lot of stuff.
Like holy shit.
Okay we're live.
I don't know if I like it.
It's just a lot of the same thing.
Yeah it is.
It's just everything in one place.
I absolutely hate the high ground.
I fucking... that was one of my complaints during testing.
During the play testing.
The high ground is like so bullshit sometimes.
Cause it's like...
Really high high ground.
Yeah yeah it's like super high.
Do you need this?
What is this?
The new stuff.
Nope but I will find a gun for it.
I mean you're playing Ramparts.
I think you should be playing the LNG.
I should.
The high ground.
I just hate the high ground so much.
The stutter!
I looked up into the city and I got the stutter.
I might have to...
360hz mod or some shit?
I have like a 280hz.
But like...
Every time I look at a specific direction.
I have a really bad stutter.
Like a terror huh?
Woah woah woah woah.
Where are they?
Oh it's over there.
Yeah the big stutter.
I will always have PC problems.
No matter where I go.
Every time I feel like I fixed my PC issue.
It just comes back.
No!
He's super low!
He's outside.
Playing up.
Res me please.
I got him.
Watch with you and PC problems.
I don't know.
I'm that unlucky no matter what happens.
Tell Zach!
No but...
Don't need a wall for that.
I'm afraid guys.
I'm afraid.
Bloodhound right here on me.
By himself.
On me.
Okay.
Down.
I go brrrr.
Woah woah woah woah.
Don't worry.
I'm doing the wrong thing.
If they come to me.
If they come to me though.
If they come to you.
What if they didn't?
If they don't then...
Woah they didn't.
They didn't.
They clearly didn't come to you.
I'll just move out.
Good luck.
Please.
Nooooooooooo!
Oh I'm dead.
There's no way.
They found me!
No!
Is that your cue of me?
Cue for us?
No!
Are you not cued?
I am.
Okay, I'm in your party.
I don't know.
I also think it's just this map.
In general.
When I swapped my AMD...
When I swapped to AMD...
My RAM usage...
increased.
I'm at like 90%.
90% That happens for AMD?
If I'm not mistaken.
Yes, lately.
What happened to our third?
Where's our third?
Okay, let's leave.
Because I don't want to play Rampart.
We're gonna die with these selections.
Do you remember to say...
XMP?
Well, I don't know.
Have you?
I don't know.
I put it in the...
computer place to do it for me.
So I don't know.
Have they?
I assume they would have.
That's also why I'm studying really hard.
So I don't know if I should...
I don't know if I should...
I still left by the way.
Because I don't want to play Rampart anymore.
Fuck Rampart.
I had no option to leave.
I'm gonna try Advantage.
No, I'm gonna try Gimpy!
He's so fun.
I am gonna try Gimpy.
My RAM speed?
Okay, I'll read my RAM speed, guys.
Alright, how do I do that?
Yeah, I'm at like 80...
I'm at 85% memory right now.
Like Task Manager performance and click memory?
There should be like... speed.
I'm at...
Speed.
Okay, speed.
50,000MT per second.
That's normal.
That's normal, yeah.
DDR5, right?
How do I see that?
God damn.
Well, I'm assuming it is.
Because mine is still 3000.
Yeah, I don't...
The stutters happened...
Ever since I swapped AMD.
So, I think I might just need more RAM.
I think, I have 32 RAM.
So I think I just need like...
What CPU did you get anyway?
I don't remember.
I don't remember because they said that a new AMD CPU was releasing in a few months.
But then I was like, obviously I need to fix it now.
And so I was like, give me the last... the best one.
Whatever the best you got.
Yeah, whatever the best you have.
But I'm already using 85% of my memory, which is not good.
How many memories do you have?
Like, let's see... OPS is using... what the fuck?
Yeah, but like in performance, how many gigs do you have?
How many gigs?
I have 32.
I have 48.
You're missing out.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
I need more RAM.
You need 64.
Why not?
Nah, I mean, you have the money!
I'm sure $110 RAM is enough.
Because Apex is using 3000 MB right now.
I don't know if I should have OBS on admin mode as well.
Maybe I should try it for...
You don't have OBS in admin mode?
Why?
No, it goes... I sometimes forget Because I, I... my new PC...
My old PC I had it automatically.
Cuz, you know, the settings.
But a new PC I never really...
I haven't really, like, put it on as automatically.
Does it only happens on stream or like... when...
on stream?
No, it's just like... this Apex just now.
It's just Apex.
But like now, right now.
Like Apex before was fine.
Like to be fair, I haven't used AMD on Apex yet.
This is the first time.
This is the first time I've used Apex for AMD, which is causing the stutters.
What?
What did he say?
Who jumped?
Why is no one wanting to jump?
Jump!
Thank you.
Alright.
Okay, I need the shield thingy.
That like... the LMG shield thingy.
That's why like I felt like it was like from the map too.
Because like, you know.
Unless like I could try a different map and...
see if it's still the same.
Honestly, I get like 170 for the least amount basically.
And for me, it's no problem.
I mean I pretty much played Apex with 40 FPS back then when it was released.
I'm kind of just yeah.
Well I'm seeing it good.
So that's why I'm like... I don't know.
I don't know if it's like from...
From...
Oh!
I got the- Oh, no.
That's a...
Yeah.
All right.
You're just...
I don't know if it's the map or... because like Stormpoint used to do that.
Stormpoint used to be like...
fucking poorly optimized because of the grass.
So like I can't tell.
I can't figure it out.
Maybe it's just Apex.
It's always... Apex has always been poorly optimized though.
It always has.
Yeah.
All right, come on, Tangent.
We need a win.
Try preload shaders.
Oh, okay.
I'll try that next game.
See if that works.
Oh yeah.
Why not that?
One on me.
Oh, one on him.
Oh, on me now.
Flash.
Knocked one.
I'm not thirsting him because of the thing.
Hey, they figured it out on Pierre.
Oh.
You're doing finish on him?
He's super low.
Okay.
On me.
Whoa!
Whoa.
All right.
They're respawning.
Are they?
Yeah.
They are?
I mean, they should.
He didn't like...
They should.
They should because we didn't kill the last guy.
Our guy didn't get his one.
We all got our ones except for him.
Shit.
Oh.
On...
Whoa.
What the...
Shhh!
Damn!
Oh, damn!
No skin.
We should not have thirsted him though.
Okay.
Sniping is like so easy.
Oh!
The highlights.
I swear.
Enemy shield.
He's flashed.
He's one.
He's literally one.
On me.
Ah, come on.
Come on.
No!
They respawned it!
They respawned!
I fucking hate you!
Get sad on!
What?
Okay.
Yeah, all my viewers are mad because I'm streaming at this hour.
No.
I mean, it's update.
What is it?
Auto reload shotguns with five allies.
Yeah.
They're over here.
By the way.
Update the game with like... within Southeast Asian time.
Oh my god!
Those drops!
Oh!
Wait.
On me?
What?
Wait.
No.
This is a different team.
This is a different team because they have a cos...
Oh shit!
Oh!
It's okay.
I'm gonna... not bleed out.
Okay.
I'm gonna bleed out.
That's right.
You don't get the kill.
I'm bled out.
I'm skinned.
Live!
Oh, I... I respawned.
Nice.
Wait.
Is it because you guys won the fight?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I'm respawning next to me.
Somebody won.
I'm respawning to the person next to me.
Alright.
Here we go.
Weeeeee!
I always have PC.
They destroyed my drone.
What is this map design?
They just literally make a turn and a corner and it doesn't lead to anywhere.
It's too complex.
They don't need this.
They're up in the top building.
No.
They killed me before I could use my eyes.
What?
Those whores!
Are they still up top?
Yeah.
Kinda are.
I kinda shot them though.
There's always another team.
Is that a Kha'Zix?
Oh my god.
Is he
actually safe or is he fucking with us?
Oh!
Green!
Alright.
I'm going for it.
I don't like the fact that I can see.
I don't know.
It feels too easy.
Yeah.
It really.
Like legit.
Use the sniper and I can see all the fucking targets with like one time scope.
It's so fucking stupid.
Yeah.
That sounds stupid.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh!
How did the stunner get worse?
How did he...
How did it get worse?
Are you on DX12?
Holy shit.
Cool.
I could be.
Oh yeah.
I destroyed a drone again.
Because the last time...
I could actually.
It's like so stupid.
Oh!
There's no scope.
Did someone drop?
Yeah.
I got him.
What the fuck is that?
Ow!
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Oh shit!
No!
What?
I was behind this wall!
Bitch!
Oh!
Here!
He should be low!
Yes!
Pull team down!
There's another team.
There's another team!
There!
It's okay.
Shield up!
I have 50 HP when I rez you.
It's okay.
Let's go.
Let's go, brother.
Let's go!
There's another team here too!
I don't even have like a med kit or anything.
Next ring isn't close.
We're not even in the ring.
That's funny.
Yeah.
I know.
Does anyone have redeploy?
We're leaving.
Holy shit!
They're all dead.
Get on top!
Oh!
Increased tactical life that...
Oh, sorry, I was looking at my thing because I haven't played.
Okay.
Don't worry, brother.
Don't worry, brother!
Oh!
Oh, no!
Don't...
Oh!
I'm okay.
I am kind of okay-ish.
What just happened?
Yeah.
Somebody's rising.
Oh, it's that.
Get out of here.
I have no shields.
We've been fighting for so long.
Don't go here!
There's a gang war here!
There's a gang war!
I'm safe, by the way.
I'm not.
Okay.
Oh, I have nothing.
Are they heals?
I need heals.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Don't there is it, you fucking liar!
Here, here, here.
I took it.
Oh, there's a gold.
Yeah, I'm gonna get that.
Grab it.
It has a shield.
We have to go.
Good thing I have that.
Fuck.
Okay.
Come on.
I'm heading over.
Let's go.
We leave.
We're at the wrong turf.
I'm at the wrong turf.
I'm sorry.
You can have this turf.
Alright.
Wee-oo.
I'm gonna try, see if I do like...
Try not to direct 12 and also preload my shaders.
Alright, guys.
Get ready to have those pre-written... have those launch command lines written for me.
What?
What did he say?
I don't know.
He said something.
I left.
Fuck that shit.
Did I say anything?
No, our third.
Our third said something.
I don't know.
I'm muting the whole... I always mute people.
You're muting it?
I always mute people in this game because...
Fuck people.
I got all on you.
Feelings don't matter.
Whoa.
Fuck your callouts.
Where are people, though?
Stop.
Where are people?
It's Southeast Asia, sir.
Where are they?
It's everywhere.
Everybody is so quiet.
Maybe I should make a coffee after this.
Oh, wait.
Nice.
I need thermites for my rampage.
Have I told you this before?
What?
It's been a month since I quit cigarettes.
Yeah, yeah.
We did.
We had a podcast, remember?
It's crazy.
How's it going?
Yeah, it's been a... I'm doing very well.
Holy shit.
You're not getting cravings?
That's really good.
No.
Holy shit.
That's actually crazy good.
I'm very, very much better.
That's good health-wise and money-wise, too.
Hell, yeah.
I stopped smoking cigarettes for a month and I could buy an RTX 4080.
Holy shit.
Oh, shit.
Wait.
Really?
It's because of the...
Oh, my God.
You could have fucking bought better PC upgrades if you fucking stopped earlier.
That's actually crazy.
That's fucked up.
That's actually fucked up.
No, I'm kidding.
I'm kidding.
Cigarettes here are cheap.
Okay, I'm gonna say it.
Thankfully, it is cheap.
Where is the fight?
Tenjin, go find them.
Use your drone.
It's right there.
Well, I can't see it.
I'm sniffing.
I can't see it, though.
Can you assume that I can see that?
You know you can right-click any ES and just see them?
No, no.
I don't know what you're talking about.
I'm playing Gibraltar.
Oh, my God.
Our crypto's not doing his job.
There.
I put drone in three.
They will not see this.
Oh, my God.
How are they supposed to see this?
Our crypto's not doing his job.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
I threw it against my Gibi.
I fucked up.
I don't want to be here.
I don't want to fight in the zone again.
I'm fucking with you.
I don't want to fight in the zone.
I don't even want to have a med kit.
Here, I have a medkit.
I don't think you can heal in time.
Oh, enemy is respawning nearby.
What the fuck is wrong with him?!
He's crying!
Somebody help him!
Is he crying?
What is he saying?
He's like, help!
Help me!
What the fuck?
It's literally like 5 am.
Why are you crying in the morning?
Here, here, here.
You dropped a medkit.
Oh, gee!
Thank you for a medkit.
I could have used that like, I don't know, five syringes ago?
Yeah, you're welcome.
That's on you!
That's literally on you!
Got you.
I got you!
I got you, bro!
Hell yeah!
Does he have anything?
I'm snared.
I'm fucking... I'm snared.
Now you can use that medkit I gave you!
Yeah!
Thank you for the medkit, doki!
Yeah, see, you're welcome!
You're welcome.
Don't worry, I got you.
I told you I got you!
Oh my god, he's so low.
There's an octane right there that's low.
This like, double shield is crazy though, not gonna lie.
Hey, I need your crypto thingy.
Hold up.
He's right there.
I knocked one.
Another guy.
Three guys here on me.
I'm shooting at my throne, you... BTs!
On me, on me, on me, on me.
That guy's one that... Oh, you're not there!
He's so low though.
Did you get that, uh, Cal... uh, conduit?
I got the fucking... what's his name?
Yeah, you got the conduit.
Oh!
I'm recharging!
He's rising!
I can't see smoke!
I'm going to die!
Okay, you guys, guys, guys, bleed out.
You guys bleed out.
I'm dead.
Bleed out.
I can live.
Maybe not.
Maybe... maybe not.
Maybe... maybe I can live.
I can live.
But trust the process.
Trust the process.
I trust the process, yes, but like...
Just trust the process.
If you don't trust the process, then you'll just die.
But like, by the time ring closes...
Trust the process.
See, I'm alive.
Sure, sure, sure, sure.
Told you to trust the process.
I don't think our guy will, like, spawn in.
Yeah, he will.
See?
Trust the process.
Where I'm at has no body.
Okay, final death, huh?
See?
Alright.
I have no ammo by the way.
I can...
Wait, wait.
Where are you?
Okay, they might land on me because...
I'm literally landed on you.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Thank God.
I was gonna say.
Last life.
Yeah, last life.
I'm gonna get in the bush.
I'm in the bush.
Alright, he's coming back.
You hear that?
He's coming back.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's saying anything?
What the fuck?
Yeah, he's like, I'm coming back.
Yeah!
Is it a kid?
No, it's a man.
That guy was so low.
Oh my God, he's giving ASMR right now.
He's literally giving ASMR.
Free ASMR.
Where are you guys shooting?
Oh, he's over there?
Yeah.
Alright.
If you say so.
I'll put the drone below.
I'm gonna do something stupid.
On me, on me, on me.
There's multiple of them.
There's a whole squad right there.
He's going away.
On me.
What are you doing?
Oh shit!
That's last life.
We have to kill him.
Did you thirst him?
Yeah.
Nice.
Give me my shields and recharge.
It's last life, Dejan.
You can't die!
I know I can't.
I'm not allowed to.
Legally, I'm not allowed to die yet.
Whoa.
Okay, I'm gonna steal his stuff.
Oh, he has the Hammond point.
I needed that too.
I mean, we're technically in zone.
I have like one...
I literally have one, uh, thermite left, so I don't want to...
Give me a sec.
Yeah, where are they?
What is your...
Cover me.
Cover my ass!
You don't have... What you didn't do off the grid?
Why didn't you do off the grid?
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Oh my god.
Okay, they have high ground so I don't know.
That shit will scan thrice.
For 15 seconds I think.
Oh my god.
I don't know.
That is actually nice.
He's like, oh my god.
No, shit!
And this is last life.
Yeah.
I know.
I'm not valuing my life at all, huh?
Yeah, I was gonna say.
Wait, what?
Are they here?
Oh no, they're just... They're above.
I can ult, but I'm gonna wait until the last second.
She could ult.
I could.
She just chose not to.
Yeah, I just chose not to.
Yeah!
I can ult then.
Wait, we should EMP the moment I...
Oh no, no, they're inside.
They're all inside.
Yeah, they're just gonna wait I feel like.
They're not gonna come out.
Like, let's just play these stairs or...
I don't know.
Here, this is closest.
This is literally the closest to the final ring.
Okay, this is the safest location I'd be right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why don't you crouch?
No.
I stand proud.
Let's see if I can get cr... No, I don't wanna...
Whoa!
This guy ain't valiant, he's like it.
Okay.
It's now or nothing, man.
Alright.
Alright, I'm doing it.
All scanned.
Oh, they're inside.
Alright.
That's funny.
Oh, that's awkward.
Ow.
That's kinda... kinda is.
That's awkward.
Alright.
I think our guy got him.
Oh, shit.
I think I got... I think we win.
Nope.
I'm just gonna stay here.
No scope.
Boom!
Alright.
Yay!
Yippee!
I won by...
doing absolutely nothing at the end.
That's all that matters.
I didn't do anything at all, so...
I just stayed outside.
I didn't even hit a single shot in that room.
I mean...
We just didn't even come out.
I wasn't gonna push in.
Like...
He's like, Yippee!
Oh my god!
Our guy was pretty good.
Yeah.
Okay, Yippee has been really fun.
I'm gonna do the new command line and see if that fixes it.
Alright, guys.
Give me the new command line.
And then I'm gonna fix that.
Alright.
Maybe I should make coffee.
How long... How long are you gonna play?
Alright.
I can play very long.
Like, legit.
I woke up at like...
6pm.
I can play like 30 more minutes.
Because I actually have to record something.
You have to record something?
I have to record!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
No way you have to record something.
Yeah!
I have to record something.
I have an Annie Rebel concert.
Oh yeah, you're a con.
Yeah.
You have to record something for it.
Best of luck on that.
Huh?
What did you say?
Best of luck on that.
Oh, thank you.
Alright, guys.
What's the command line?
That I have to do?
The launch option.
Alright.
Add the preload?
Okay.
This.
I'll copy that.
What about the... I wanna make sure I'm not playing on 12.
DirectX 12.
How do I...
How do I force it to be DirectX 11 instead?
Why am I getting 300 pings and 300 pings?
Why are you getting 300 pings?
I don't know because... No, it's not pre-recorded but there's a...
Guys, there's something there, remember?
Hor, hor, hor, hor, hor.
Hahahaha!
You made me choke me on my word, you bitch!
You trying to kill me?
You fu...
Hahahaha!
Goddamn!
The fuck was that?
That was so random.
That was like, out of...
Hor, hor, hor, hor.
That was so random!
That was so fucking random.
What the fuck was that?
Guys, guys, guys.
What's the command line to force DirectX 11?
Guys!
I need it.
Okay.
Okay, I have this.
What else do I need to add in there?
I wanna fix this before I take it to the PC doctor again.
I don't know.
Just straight up say, Hor, hor, hor, hor.
Doesn't even fucking elaborate what it's all about.
Like, what the fuck?
There's no need for elaboration!
Also, like, I can tell that...
I can tell when I'm fighting a controller player because...
Holy shit.
That nerve is actually hitting them so hard.
Like, they can't actually aim now.
It's actually coming.
It's actually crazy.
They can't aim anymore.
I love it.
Because, like, it's fucking with their muscle memory.
It's actually fucking with their muscle memory.
And I can tell.
Until they get used to it.
But, like, this is the time to take advantage of...
of their lack of muscle memory.
Alright.
Let's see.
Let's see if it works now.
Waiting for game.
Alright.
At best, if I'll ever...
At best, I'll just get more RAM installed.
Because, like, my old PC had, like, max RAM.
64?
Yeah.
That's not the max.
Wait, that's not?
What's the max?
120.
Holy shit.
Wait, what?
Unable to connect to EA server?
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Is the server down or is it just the command line that I put out?
I don't know.
I can't tell!
I can't tell you that as well.
Because... I can't tell!
I can't tell if it's my command line!
Everything has been blocked here.
This is unable to connect!
It could be my command line that I put down.
I won't be surprised.
It's always me.
Alright, guys.
Guys, what do I change?
I have this!
Alright, restart?
Okay, I'm gonna start.
I'll restart.
Hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor!
Hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor, hoor!
Did you see, like, people were, like, debating about what FNAF was gonna be collabing with?
Everybody was like, if it's not Fortnite, I'm gonna be so fucking mad.
It's dead by daylight.
And then it's dead by then.
Alright,
here we go.
If the restart doesn't work...
Oh my god, unable to connect.
Wait, make sure Steam is...
Is Steam online?
Wait, Steam isn't online.
Wait.
Oh my god, when is Steam coming back?
Why is everything never going to work?
Why am I so unlucky?
When does Steam come back?
This is why I don't use Steam.
Why am I so unlucky?
I don't understand!
It should be in 3-5 minutes.
Okay.
Calm down, it's Tuesday.
I am calm!
I don't know what you're talking about!
Everything's going wrong!
Bye!
Alright, don't worry, I'm fine.
I'm okay.
Surely nothing is wrong.
I just...
I don't know, I feel like I'm just cursed to always have PC problems...
For the rest of my life.
Some people are like that, I'll be honest.
I feel like I've never been lucky.
I've never been lucky...
You've never been lucky...
I have never been lucky.
I say this in front of Tenjin.
Tenjin, I've never been lucky in my life.
I say as I make thousands of dollars.
I say as like I make thousands of dollars every month.
I'm not lucky, Tenjin.
This 3000 plus dollars PC is not working as I intended.
White's like, here's a 100 dollar bill.
Man, I am grateful to be donated one dollar by a fan.
Hey man, anything goes to my bills.
Holy shit.
When does the Steam maintenance come back?
There's a Steam maintenance.
Yes, it's Tuesday.
Oh, so that was a thing.
Yeah, this is why I play on EA.
Bro.
Fuck you, bro.
Holy shit.
Okay, so...
Yeah, but I don't like playing on EA app.
It's just not convenient.
True.
It's not very convenient at all.
Oh my god.
Please.
I just...
I just wanna be part...
Guys!
Tell me when Steam is back, guys!
Guys, tell me when Steam is back.
You know I took public transport today, Tenjin.
I haven't taken public transport in a very long time here in Canada.
And like, I told my chat this, but I had to Google how to pay for bus.
Because I...
You don't...
You don't know how to fucking ride a bus?
I was confused.
Cause like, I...
No, I do.
But like, like the last time I rode a bus was in university.
And so like...
Uh-huh.
So I was just...
But they gave us...
They changed the system?
I don't know.
What if they did?
The last time they gave...
We had like university passes that work on buses.
So like...
Right.
Obviously, I'm not in university anymore.
So I was just like, how to pay for...
Cause I don't carry change.
I didn't wanna fucking use change.
Cause I don't carry any.
So I was just like, how do you pay for bus?
You get the card?
How do you...
Yeah, but like...
I was like, where get card?
Like...
I don't have my...
What's that name again?
I still have my Opus card.
Oh, the one in Japan?
No, in Montreal.
Oh!
This is how little I know about the public transport system.
Like...
It's not convenient though.
I feel like...
Compared to like Asia public transport, the public transport in Canada is not that convenient.
Like...
Uh...
I don't wanna talk about convenient in my time here.
Oh yeah.
Do you wanna know how to stop the bus?
No, the bus doesn't stop.
You have to fucking drop down the bus while it's moving.
Holy shit.
Yeah.
I was just like, how...
Where do I...
Cause I didn't wanna pay for...
Cause like I'm in the middle of a move.
So I did...
Cause...
But like I have to go back to my old...
Like this place.
My old place.
Cause we did...
I didn't move my PC setup.
So like...
I didn't want to Uber.
I didn't want to Uber like every day to like back to my apartment and like back to my new apartment.
So like I had to...
I was like, okay, I have to learn the public transport for real this time.
Like I don't want to pay like so much money every day just to go back and forth.
So...
Just get a card.
I did!
That's what the Googling was for!
I got the card cause that's what the Googling was!
I learned about the card because of Google!
So we were just like, just drive.
I haven't been behind the car wheel, the wheel of a car to drive in like...
I think like nine plus years now, guys.
I will not touch a car because of that.
Because I'm worried.
Like I should not be like...
I should not even have my license because I haven't touched a car for that long.
You should like...
I haven't touched a car in like five years.
Like I've been a passenger.
Like I had like chauffeurs.
Like as in...
I lost my driver's license.
As in my parents and...
Like my parents and Uber.
Like I never had to drive myself.
I literally got my license so I could go to a bar and be like, here's my license.
Like...
Use my ID.
I literally got the driver's license.
So like, you know, when you pick up packages or you go to the bar and they ID you, I don't have to bring my passport.
I could just be like, here's my ID.
That's literally the only reason why I wanted to drive.
I didn't care.
I never...
After I got my driver's license, I never drove the car.
Like legit.
Legit.
Took the test.
Did the driving test.
Never touched a car after that.
I think you might be Indonesian.
There was no use.
Can you connect yet?
I don't know.
Is Steam back on yet?
I was like chat, tell me when Steam's back on.
Alright, let me check.
No, I'm still disconnected.
I thought it says 3 to 5 minutes.
Yeah, Steam is dead, dude.
Yes, it's Steam Tuesday.
Tuesday Steam.
Right.
What do you mean driving is so convenient?
Yeah, but like...
It's scary.
Sure.
It's...
It's like, okay, the reason why I hate driving is because like, I don't want...
What if I like accidentally like run over somebody?
You're so white.
Like, it's like the possibility...
Commit vehicular manslaughter.
I'm just like, what if I accidentally, you know, just accidentally run over somebody?
I don't want to deal with that.
The heck happened to your license?
As long as...
Yeah, it got confiscated.
Yes.
Yeah, how did your license get confiscated?
What did you do?
Illegal racing.
Definitely.
That is supposed to not like happen.
But hey.
Hey, man, I needed money.
You got caught?
Look at him.
Hey, man, I needed money.
Look at that.
He got caught.
No, no.
The thing is...
Okay, the story was...
Okay, again, I don't condone this, but the guy who was supposed to pay the road, quote, unquote, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
Took away the money and run away.
So, so...
I don't know.
Headless and ha-ha.
Oh, what the fuck?
Yeah.
Oops.
They...
They took the money?
Yeah, they took the money.
That's fucking crazy.
They didn't pay.
They ran away with the money.
Holy shit.
That's crazy.
That's actually insane.
Anyway, do you still...
Do you still...
Will you still do it?
Will you still illegally race?
I haven't even touched the car in five years man.
Wait in five... that was five years ago?
Yeah because I cannot issue a new license.
That's the thing.
Oh because like it's gone gone forever?
I'm banned.
I can apply now.
Oh okay.
Yeah why don't you apply for it?
We don't have a car.
Oh shit.
I was gonna say.
I was like...
Oh whoa.
Guys.
Why is the maintenance still going on?
I don't understand.
I just want a game.
Guys.
I just want to play the video game.
Alright.
How long do Steam maintenance last?
We try... it usually lasts less than an hour.
What?
When did it start?
When did the maintenance start?
20 minutes?
It was like... 20 minutes?
No it's like supposed to be 20 minutes.
Sorry.
20 fucking minutes.
Oh in a minute.
Then it should be done in a... I can't believe I locked out of Apex.
The moment the Steam maintenance started.
I'm so unlucky.
I think you're still connected.
No I would be.
That's the thing.
You would be.
I think you would be.
That's actually so... I'm so unlucky.
I swear to God.
I'm so unlucky.
I cry on my $50 bills.
I say as Tenjin's fucking driver's license got confiscated because of illegal driving.
I...
Someone was like only $50 bills.
Oh no guys.
$5 is enough to feed me for two weeks.
Tenjin it's not about you right now.
It's about...
Yeah it's... clearly not.
Oh my god.
It's awful.
It's not...
Oh my god.
I'm so sad.
I think the worst part is the fact that I have to take the PC back because I don't know how... I'm scared of adding RAM to my PC.
The fuck?
It's just a RAM.
I'm scared.
Oh.
But like...
But what if I...
Apply me there and I'll install your app.
I might as well fucking put it in game!
It's really cheaper than fucking bring this in.
That's the thing.
Just put it in yourself.
I'm scared of breaking it.
What if I break it?
Then you'll get another PC.
Yeah, but I can't fucking...
Getting a new PC is like...
It takes a lot of time.
Oh yeah, I could ask them.
I could actually ask Kyle.
It will be a content.
Flying my Indonesian friend to Canada to install my RAM.
Hyatt was actually down to buy for any upgrades and stuff.
So I just need to message them.
Can you compensate for my more RAM, please?
Oh, thank you.
Thank you so much, Ritual.
Someone throw you $50.
No, they threw...
They gave me some tissues.
Oh my god, thank you, Ritual, for the tissues.
My $50 tissues.
Oh my god.
The tissues are real.
Just for you.
My $50.
Tissue funds are so real.
So real.
Alright.
I lost the $50 already.
I lost it.
Pizza time.
Someone sent me pizza time.
Where's the tissue?
I need tissue as well.
Where's your tissue?
Don't worry.
Okay, you know what?
Never mind.
Food is so real.
No, no, no, no.
You want tissues, Ten?
We are not in the pandemic.
Don't worry, Tenjin.
Don't worry.
What the fuck?
$20 tissue?
Here's your tissue.
Wait.
No, I don't.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
I'm not...
I'm not gonna find my credit card.
You don't even get tissues from me.
I'm not even...
I was gonna give you a $2 super chat.
I'm sorry.
And be like, here's a tissue.
From my $50 super chat.
I was gonna give you $2.
And be like, here's a tissue.
If you are throwing tissues, I'm scared now.
But like...
I can't be bothered to like...
find my credit card right now.
I was defeated by laziness.
Why the fuck would I remember my credit card?
I somehow remember mine.
Because I'm too lazy to get it.
Are you okay now?
No, why am I still disconnected?
How do I force it to connect to my Steam?
Oh no.
Okay.
Here's a tissue for Tenjin.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for the tissues.
If we add it all up, I can use it all at once.
To get a new RAM.
Okay.
Let's see.
I do need RAM though.
I feel like RAM would fix... RAM always fix things.
You know you can install 256 GB of RAM.
But I don't know.
I don't know if I have...
I don't know if it fits.
That's the thing.
Okay.
Wait.
Why isn't it not...
Okay.
I'm going to restart my Steam.
Wait.
No.
If I restart my Steam, then I disappear.
God.
There's so many issues.
Guys.
How do I...
How the fuck do I like...
Why is it disconnected?
Why are you disconnected?
I'm a mess.
I'm a mess right now.
Why is it disconnected?
I don't understand.
Is this...
How am I offline?
Okay.
I'm going to restart Apex.
Oh my god.
We can finally play a fucking game.
We literally played two games.
We played two games.
This is the Doki experience.
Every time Apex.
Just Apex.
Apex doesn't want to Apex sometimes.
Yeah.
We won the game.
That's all that matters, right?
Alright.
What is it?
Our third.
It carried us to victory.
Alright.
I swear to god.
Let me in.
Go to top right Steam.
Then go online.
But like...
I am online.
It's just... I'm not.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh!
I'm in.
You're in?
Find me.
I'm in.
Invite me.
I'm preloading.
Okay.
I'm not actually in.
But like... I can play for like...
I can play for like 40 more minutes.
I'm gonna cry.
I got my time wrong.
Fan merch?
Tissues?
No.
My fan merch would be like...
Oh my god.
You should make fan merch for...
You should make official... I'm gonna make official merch.
Where like the tissues are like super chats.
And then...
Wait.
That's so smart.
If I were to have a merch, it's gonna be a cigarette.
I don't even know like...
Bro!
Oh my god.
Can you like... Oh that would be...
I wonder if you can make like a tissue box with like tissues.
And then the tissues are like color coded to the super chats.
And then like the box itself would be...
Would be like you know me crying.
And be like...
Please I...
Super chats with tissues.
It would be color coded.
Into like super chats.
Careful.
Into the box itself.
I wonder if I can get that made.
Use the tissues?
No.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
I'm loading in.
Oh my gosh.
Is this the preload shaders part?
Chat is this why it's taking so long?
Is it loading in my shaders right now?
Is it...
Jesus Christ.
People are throwing stuff.
I'm...
Wait they're throwing stuff?
Yeah.
The super chat tissue box.
Oh my god.
It could go viral.
It could go definitely viral.
Holy shit guys you just beat my mom people.
Does anybody know a guy at clinics?
Wait.
Oh my god.
I want color coded tissues.
Wait I'm gonna look that up right now.
Is that possible?
I'm gonna look up some manufacturers.
Tissues.
I'm looking up for manufacturers.
Tissue manufacturers.
Tissue paper manufacturers.
Is that actually possible?
Oh my god.
You can have custom logo.
On like tissue boxes.
But can I customize the tissue color?
Like that's what I want.
You can.
There are colored tissues.
Is there colored tissues?
I've got a black toilet paper for some fucking no reason.
I want to know.
I am fascinated.
Oh my god.
And then wait you can.
And you know like the best part.
Because like if you use it.
Like it will be.
You know people can use up a tissue box.
Like tissue box.
So like force them to buy more tissue boxes.
And I'm gonna have the monopoly on Vtuber tissue boxes.
Dude I steal.
If anybody fucking steals my merch idea.
I swear.
I'm gonna change my clothes.
I swear to god.
That's the game.
If I see another Vtuber releases a tissue box.
Before I release the tissue box.
I swear to god.
I'm just kidding.
I need a patent.
Patent it.
Real fast.
You're gonna make a patent?
Yeah.
Oh there you are.
I'm here now.
Okay.
I can't ready up yet.
Prepare for some fan merch.
Wait.
Trios is back?
Quads is back?
I think there's something wrong with my camera.
I think something is wrong with my camera.
I'm gonna go to fire.
Okay we're gonna fire range real fast.
And then get back in.
No but my specific.
Tissue box.
I will have a monopoly.
On Vtuber tissue boxes.
Cause I will figure out how to color code it.
So that it's like blue, orange, yellow, pink, red and everything.
And then okay.
My game is fixed.
You can invite me now.
Cause like for some reason my game.
You can have four players.
It had like quad mode back on.
I was like that's not right.
Yeah you're back.
I like I de-patched it.
I downgraded my patch.
Holy shit.
I will have that brand.
Okay I'm gonna look up customizable.
Luxurious.
Tissue okay.
Can I like customize the tissue color?
What's the name for it then?
Wait I can!
Wait can I?
You can.
You can have colored tissues.
Oh my god I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna fucking do it.
I don't fucking know.
Super Chat Tissue Box.
The Super Chat Tissues.
I'm gonna do Super Chat Tissues.
I'll make the...
And then the box will be like me crying.
And be like Super Chat Tissues.
And it will be like different colors.
And stuff.
This is the birth of my billion dollar idea.
This is gonna be a...
Oh my god I should make it!
Wipe your butt with Super Chats!
I should do it.
This is a billion dollar idea Chat.
Like this is actually a billion dollar.
Like this is actually a billion dollar idea Chat.
Since it's a super niche.
If I'm the only one that has made it...
then like I'll be the only person...
that people have to buy it from...
That is so smart!
Oh my god.
It's not weird.
Okay it's a little weird.
This is pretty weird.
It is like why would you use that instead of like clinics or like
That instead of like clinics or like all the other big brands
But a Vtuber has not made merch of it!
Also why is there 13 players in queue?
Has this game died already?
The season failed 13 players in queue?
Only 13 players in queue in all of Asia.
In all of Asia.
That's actually crazy No dude there's no face!
The tissues are just super chat colors!
There's no fucking face on it!
Bro that's what the fuck is wrong with you guys and you say I was weird My idea was just to make it super chat colors I think I might need the tissue now
The box will have my face on it!
Toilet paper with my face on it.
Okay, that's your merch idea.
That's not I don't take credit for that.
That's my merch.
Yeah, yeah, that's your merch.
I don't I'm not taking that.
I'm not taking that idea.
Freaky hours not gonna lie.
I'm gonna google colored Tissues.
I'm not googling sorry.
I'm gonna look it up.
Oh my god!
You can actually have like...
Wait, that's crazy.
You can have orange color.
You can have orange colored tissue toilet paper Yeah, legit.
I bought like a black toilet paper for no reason and I kind of like it.
Oh my god Oh my god, that is...
But there's a little bit of a downside you can't tell if you clean it properly or not Oh, why did you say that?
I didn't want to know!
Why did you say that?
Hey man, I'd say you wouldn't even know!
Why?
This is why it's white!
Oh my god.
You called me weird, chat!
You called me weird!
I don't call you weird.
No, I said chat!
Mine was just to wipe your tears.
It's just to wipe your tears.
That was my idea.
Of super chat money.
But...
Don't you have a bidet?
Don't you?
Yeah, we have a bidet.
Yeah, I was gonna say what the fuck do you have?
Because it's a black color.
It's interesting.
I've never seen it.
I was like why were you using toilet paper when you have a bidet?
You don't need to buy...
You really don't need to buy toilet paper anymore.
I want a bidet.
Can I like have...
Can I just have a bidet installed with a rental?
Yeah, you can.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I have a rental.
I want a bidet.
I want to just install a bidet.
Just like get a bidet shower.
Not a bidet seat.
It's just a bidet shower.
What the fuck is a bidet shower?
You don't know what a toilet bidet is?
I live in N.A.
The toilet paper company has...
has lobbied against bidets.
And like spread fake news about bidets.
And like...
All the things you learn from.
Holy shit.
And they like...
They like got rid of like...
They made bidets not popular in N.A.
Because they're like...
Bidets are not useful.
But like they are.
I want a...
I want a bidet.
I want to go back to bidets.
How is there 30?
What the fuck?
Why is no one playing this game?
No one is up in the game yet.
I don't understand.
Alright you're coming to N.A.
Leave.
No I'm not.
You're going to N.A.
I literally have 30 minutes left to game.
Attention.
Why do you only have 30 minutes?
Because I have to do recording.
I told you.
After recording we play the game.
Oh my god.
We're going to N.A.
Leave my lobby and join back.
Go leave.
N.A's queue is at least a bit alive.
Are you in yet?
I can't even go to your lobby.
Alright.
Where are you?
Where the fuck are you?
I think I'm invisible.
Hold on.
You don't even exist.
On my friends list.
Where the fuck are you?
There.
I'm online.
Oh there you are.
Alright get in here.
We're going to N.A.
I swear to god this is instant.
I swear to god.
More tissue funds.
I'm going to have a heart attack.
Don't fall for big toilet paper lies.
JP thank you for the super chat.
Big toilet paper lies.
Oh my god look we're almost in game.
We're at 44 players in queue.
How did this get?
I don't understand.
The patch came out in like 11, 12, 1, 2, 3, 4.
In like 6 hours ago.
Sorry I had to count my fingers because I can't.
Numbers.
The patch literally came out 6 hours ago.
How are we waiting in queue?
Like I don't understand.
Oh my god.
I'm so confused.
You can't be like Steam was down.
Steam's back up.
It's back up now.
How?
No I'm in N.A.
now.
I'm in N.A.
This game's dead.
There's more people left?
There's more people in Tarkov than this game apparently.
God damn.
What are they playing?
I can literally only play one game mode.
And rank.
What else are they playing?
What's the other one?
Are they playing bot royale?
We're playing bot royale.
I actually tried bot royale.
It's so goofy.
It is so goofy.
I swear it's so goofy.
At least we can fill up the server.
With fucking bots.
At least we can.
Oh my god.
Why does it take forever to fucking set up bot royale?
This is...
What is wrong with this game?
There's two players in queue.
Yes there should be only two players in queue.
The rest are bots.
Okay there we go.
Alright we're playing bot royale right now.
I can't.
I just wanna shoot my gun.
I swear it's goofy as shit.
Is Fanatic Whisper a real player or like a bot?
You'll see.
I'll see?
We'll see.
Alright.
Okay.
Who do I wanna play that kills players fast?
World Edge.
We don't have to try hard cop this.
I mean they're literally all bots.
Alright let's see.
Let's see this real...
This very real person.
Oh yeah that's not real.
There's no way.
Someone was like did your command line ruin the queuing system?
That should not be possible.
How would command lines ruin a queue?
Like destroy a queue.
How?
Did I just get into an easy mode?
Is this a PC lobby?
Probably.
Wait.
I don't know.
Okay we're leaving bot 5.
We're gonna kill one team and then we're leaving bot royale.
And then we're gonna see if that's true.
There is a way.
Guys there's actually a way.
Because like...
Because like back there was a command line.
Where you can like...
Force a PC lobby.
Without like...
Jesus Christ.
They're so good at fucking defending their shields.
That's...
Like...
Literally this bot was so good at making sure I don't shoot him.
When he put up his shield.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Hello.
Oh my god.
Give me my fucking shield back you...
No!
It's so goofy I swear.
Oh my god.
Bots have zero ping.
Okay yeah it's definitely not the map.
It's my RAM issue I'm pretty sure.
It's in my RAM A and D.
I'm just gonna get new RAM.
Fuck it.
Get more RAM.
But it has to be the same RAM right?
That's like...
Well...
It's safer to be the same yes.
Yeah yeah.
Alright are you ready to leave and fucking try again?
I shot my gun I'm satisfied.
I can wait longer.
Honestly my FPS is also like 150 for some fucking reason.
That's weird.
Did they just break the game?
AMD is the best with only one stick?
RAM issue.
No it's not.
Wait what?
That's what somebody in my chat said.
What?
Oh they deleted their message.
Yeah yeah I was like what?
No wait someone said AMD isn't stable with four sticks.
That's what they say.
It's not.
Kind of not.
I have four sticks in there.
Eww.
Someone said two 32 gigabyte sticks.
That's what they said.
Eww.
Yeah that's what...
Wait there's no revival in my game?
Did they remove revival?
What?
Revival?
They can do that?
How?
Okay we're leaving.
I'm so confused.
We're leaving?
Then why are you still moving?
Because like now I'm leaving.
Now I'm...
Uh huh.
You just turned into a box.
Wait what?
There's still revival!
Somebody was like there's no revival anymore.
But there's still revival in my fucking thing!
Alright queue up.
What are you guys talking about?
There's revival here!
You guys are big liars.
Big big liars.
You know what I'll go...
Oh we got in.
Okay let's go.
We're in.
That's fine.
We fixed it.
We just had to...
Uh...
Yeah they removed it.
Then what am I in?
Then why are we even like...
What am I in?
Somebody super chatty said like...
Yeah they removed it.
What am I in?
Big liars.
Where am I?
What is going on?
It's called launch day.
It's called Apex Legends launch day.
How the fuck?
Where are we?
Are we in the matrix?
Where the fuck are we?
Alright.
Are you playing Mirage?
I'm gonna play...
I'm gonna play crypto.
I'm going off the grid again.
What is reality?
Where's that guy?
Super chat explain this.
Explain this.
Now they removed my trios.
What the fuck?
You were the one that got your trios removed.
Not me.
Oh yeah we won.
You were the issue.
Alright.
We're back in.
Apparently they said to try a new command line.
So I'm gonna try a new command line after this game.
Try a new command line?
Yeah.
We're gonna keep trying command lines.
Until we prove forces.
You know what?
Maybe I should too.
Because probably getting 150 in Apex is not...
Probably.
My FPS decreases when I upgrade my graphics card.
I don't think that's a normal thing.
Something will work eventually.
Probably.
Not even...
That's not even me.
Why here?
Oh they're like nearly next to me.
They're hinging nearly.
Are you fighting already?
Yes I am.
I'm fucking coming back though.
Because he has a team.
Woah.
I got the rampart though.
Hello?
Go drone go!
Not even me.
Go Nikoi go!
Man.
Enemies are respawning?
I didn't even kill anybody yet.
Alright.
I'm coming over now.
Right here.
There's a Venture coming in.
There's a Venture.
Where is he?
What?
Do you even have a gun?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Alright.
You're down one.
You're down two.
Don't worry I got you!
Wait you're not him.
Alright.
I need to grab some...
I need to grab some ammo.
I have zero ammo.
How do you have zero ammo?
Like my...
Because I shot people.
Because you shot people and didn't kill them.
What do you think?
Yeah they don't have my ammo!
You know what?
Fuck you.
I'm going off the grid.
I'll need you.
What?
Fuck you.
Because of what you said I'm going off the grid now.
Good luck.
What?
I'm burning off my fingerprints and deleting my passports.
Where?
There's people here.
Hey there buddy.
Hey.
Hey there.
Am I shooting your drones?
No.
Alright.
Alright exit.
I'm coming back now.
That's not mine by the way.
Bro is so blind.
Where are you?
Just one second late.
Oh god.
I'm going off the grid.
Oh shit!
They broke my fucking...
Wait that's you.
It's me.
I don't even know...
What?
What do you mean?
Fucking...
Wow!
There's so many people.
There's a lot of people.
You should... I'm leaving.
I should what?
You should leave.
There's a lot.
There's a new team coming in.
Don't worry.
Off the grid time.
Sure.
Off the grid.
Don't worry.
I'm contributing!
They're right here.
You know...
Fuck these guys in particular.
They're up here by the way.
They don't know.
Oh that guy is super low.
I'm fine.
There's people in front of me.
No!
They saw me before I disappeared.
What happened to your eye for the grid?
They saw me.
I came back to visit relatives.
And they caught me at the border control.
They caught me at the border.
I'm back.
I knew it.
I should have never came back.
Family is dead to me after I go off the grid.
My fucking 10 passports didn't work.
Alright.
I'm going on the other side.
There is like a guy next to me.
I can't see you guys from here.
There's another squad.
Hailna.
Is there?
Yep.
I'm here.
Where are they?
Well, I ain't fighting that.
Where?
Oh shit!
Don't fight that!
That's what I'm talking about.
Three squads?
Okay.
There's three squads.
Don't leave it.
You have to.
Oh shit!
You guys are doing stuff.
Wait, are they dead?
I'm going to scout.
Yeah, they're all dead.
Oh no, no, no!
Right here, right here!
They're on my side.
Somebody is taking zip.
They ran off.
Alright, I'm going to loot.
Where's the other Mozambique, bro?
Damn!
I need like another P20.
I need another Mozambique.
Did you kill one guy only?
I killed like seven.
I'm going to get rid of these then.
Oh my god.
I'm going to heal up them.
Okay.
Oh, on me.
I'm going to kill them.
Oh shit!
Oh, that's the bitch.
Yeah, that's him.
Oh, you got him!
Flash, flash, flash!
He's one.
He's literally one.
Punch him!
Yeah, I told you.
I need his loot.
Did they have a fucking Mozambique?
Wait, where did he go?
Where did the body go?
I don't know.
I thought he dropped down.
I see it.
Oh, he's down there?
Yeah, he's right there.
What about the other one?
I don't fucking know.
I need to find...
Oh, I got... I got double...
I got double P20s.
You got double Mozambique.
We got this.
Okay.
Uh...
Alright.
You need double Mozambique.
I'll find... I'll ping you a Mozambique when I see one.
Sure, sure, sure.
Uh...
Is there anybody here?
One squad?
Where is this one squad?
They said there's a squad here.
Hello?
It's like... It's like the whole drone range, basically.
Oh, they're on the other side.
They're on the other side.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Um... Do you have any shield cells?
I have zero.
I have three.
That's not even a battery.
It's a cell.
Alright.
This is a little awkward.
Oh!
Very, very awkward.
I found some cells.
Get over here.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
There's like teams to our left.
Yeah.
And a right.
And that one guy.
Yeah, but he can't be a solo because, you know, this is...
They could leave.
Oh, that's true.
They could be assholes.
Yeah, like no one wants to play with you.
There.
Here.
You have no friends.
That's so sad.
Nice.
You have no friends.
Alright.
Where are we?
What?
There was people here.
Where are they?
Over here.
I hear them.
Shh.
They're on me?
Oh, that's a huge car.
The fuck?
Oop.
Not here.
Alright.
Don't worry.
Connecting?
Holy shit.
That is invisible.
Over here.
I see them.
It's right here.
Damn.
Shooting people from this distance and this...
What the fuck?
I see!
Oh my god.
I got back to see the flame around me.
That's actually so fucked.
My... my bat.
Alright.
Our guy is moving fast.
Oh my god.
He's already there.
Mm-hmm.
Okay.
I'm gonna do something crazy.
Stupid mosquitoes.
Pew!
There you go.
They're all low.
I'm back.
They're all so low.
I did my job.
Are they all dead?
Wait.
They're all dead.
Holy shit.
That was fast.
Oh my god!
Gold dual pistols?
Wow!
Chill!
Not me.
Right here.
Holy shit.
That's a lot.
They're right.
Oh my god.
He's literally one.
Did you get the bloodhound?
Yeah.
I got the bloodhound.
Okay.
I got him.
Where's the last guy?
He's at the corner where my decoy is.
I don't know.
He's in smoke.
You ping?
Oh there he is.
Bro this guy.
I'm coming over.
Bro this guy ain't raising me.
He's just...
He's fucking running his zone.
That's fucking crazy.
He can't live there.
He'll die.
Is he still alive in there?
Kind of.
How is he still alive?
There's no way.
He shan't be.
He actually...
Oh my god.
He actually lived long enough for...
He's dead.
He actually lived long enough just for the respawn.
That's actually crazy.
He did that.
That bitch.
Is there no second Mozambique?
Holy shit.
I have not seen it.
I don't think anybody is running it.
I am soloing people with like one singular Mozambique.
I found a lot of shotgun ammo.
Oh they dropped down.
Yeah.
They dropped that way.
That's the team earlier.
Right.
I can't believe my fucking rat lived for that long.
Can you recall?
Get in zone and then I can...
do stuff.
On me?
Right here?
Crypto?
He's right in front of us.
Oh but like... Oh shit!
You okay?
Our guy is not okay.
Damn.
I'm not disappearing.
They are fucking in.
Oh it's just lifeline.
No!
I'm dead.
No I'm so dead.
No!
I wanted to disappear!
I couldn't disappear!
I couldn't!
No!
Okay wait.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do one last command line and we can do one last game.
You know what?
Maybe I should too.
Alright let's both...
Let's do some commands.
No!
They saw me before...
Like this game is ass.
They saw me before I disappeared!
Before I could...
Before I could shred...
my VMAs for it.
Alright guys.
What is the new command line?
I gave you a chance to use my P20!
That's the worst part.
I didn't get my gold P20 because...
No you don't.
It's literally...
No I'm trying to switch back to DX11.
Alright guys.
This is my current command line.
What do I have to fix?
Guys.
Hold up guys.
Alright.
Refresh rate high.
Okay.
I'll refresh.
I'll add that in.
I'm gonna add in my fucking command line.
All the text that's in there.
You know what?
I'm gonna get rid of the DX11.
I'm gonna get rid of that.
And then I'm gonna use this.
I'm gonna use this command line.
I don't know if I should.
Force Reload.
This fucking Valve game.
Alright.
Here it is.
This is gonna be my command line.
My newest one.
My newest...
Command is getting bigger.
The newest... I don't even know.
I should just fucking...
And I'm also gonna shop for 2 sticks of 32 gigabytes.
Alright.
My last...
My last command line.
Of the day.
And then we're just gonna...
Add more RAM later.
Add more RAM.
We're expanding.
The desk we haven't expanded before.
Yay RAM.
I'm gonna eat some RAMs.
Alright.
Let's try.
Continue.
Alright.
I'm ready whenever you are.
Does this work?
Am I switching back to the X11?
I don't fucking know.
I don't know.
I...
I'm waiting on you now.
Let's see then.
Play.
This game is stupid.
How... Where to download...
More...
RAM.
Yes.
My TJ!
I only have one game left!
Okay!
What are you adding in?
I... I am...
I am waiting for game.
Oh you're waiting... Oh the shaders?
Yes.
It just says wait for game.
Alright.
I'm here.
I'm here to wait.
It's waiting for game.
Alright.
Are you still waiting?
I'm in.
I have received a hundred Apex coins.
Should we try Asia?
No.
Okay.
I mean sure.
What?
My maze.
I'm fucking trying to find you.
You're not on.
I am.
No you're not.
I literally don't see you.
I am.
Look thoroughly.
Engine.
No.
I'm on.
No you're not.
Yes!
I'm right there bro.
Okay now you are.
I'm right there dude.
Alright.
Back to...
Okay.
I don't want to play crypto anymore.
I want to play...
Oh yeah I wanted to play Vantage.
I wanted to try Vantage.
See look at these insta-queues.
Look at these insta-queues.
Singapore could never.
Yeah!
Alright.
Oh yeah.
Now they're playing.
Don't play.
Yeah.
See where the double akimbo third weapon slot would be.
Alright.
Alright after this stream.
I'm going to look up to see if my local PC stores have like 32 gigabytes of RAM.
Are you on DDR5?
I don't fucking know.
I need to look at my specs again.
I need to...
She doesn't even know her specs.
I don't know it on the top of my head.
Wow.
Look I'm going through a lot right now.
Oh you're going through a lot.
Sure buddy.
Sure.
Surely.
Surely you are.
Where is SuperGuna going to go?
Come on Gooner.
Alright here we go.
Here we go.
Honestly I still haven't seen the whole map.
I feel...
I don't know.
All the places blur together for me.
Because they're all very similar.
You know?
Yes.
They all look very similar so I...
I can't tell what's new.
Bro what the fuck is wrong with you?
That's not fair.
This guy took my loot.
There's like a guy on my house.
Oh my god.
This is not fair.
He gets like a fucking L-Star.
Where are you?
On my building.
Nice.
Yeah he was one.
Oh shit!
This is fucked up.
I should send out a bat.
Pew!
Over there.
Nice.
What did you get bitch?
I need like heals.
Oh they're respawning.
Where?
Enemy down.
Nice.
Deserves.
How dare they.
I'm gonna loot your shit too.
I know you earned that kill.
But I'm gonna loot it.
Oh I hear them.
Oh.
It automatically doubles the Mozambique.
I need a Mozambique too.
Wait.
I have a hammerpoint.
Do you want it?
Wait I should have double Mozambique.
Nevermind.
JK.
On me.
Woah!
I got fucking...
Dude he got fucked up.
No!
He was one!
One!
Live!
No!
He left.
Our guy left.
No!
He left.
You're supposed to spawn.
Oh wait.
No he did spawn.
He did spawn.
Yeah he did spawn.
That's fucking crazy.
He left but he...
He left but he clutched it.
Oh my god.
He actually left but it counted.
It fucking counted.
Thank god.
Thank fucking god.
Wow.
Alright.
I'm alive.
That's all that matters.
Let's see.
Where are you?
I'm dropping down.
Apparently like you don't...
Wait.
I thought you don't have to look.
Wait what?
I thought they updated so that you don't have to look at the echo.
I might as well read it.
Did I read the patch run?
What was it?
Did you read it correctly?
I think I... I mean I can't read.
So I'm pretty...
Right.
Sure.
I can't read so most likely yeah.
Oh.
Most likely.
Fancy pants reading.
Where are they?
I scanned them.
They should be over there.
They're like right there.
Like in that building.
Do you see that?
Did they upgrade it?
No.
Refresh, tackle, improve it.
Gain access to ring content.
I don't see them.
Oh they're fighting.
I guess we go.
I'm gonna go up.
Can we go up?
Nice.
Oh below.
Are they like...
Whoa!
Okay.
They're like right below us.
Wait can you ping them?
Oh I'm... I'm... I'm...
I'm snared.
I got one.
Got the other.
You bitch.
It's okay.
Our super goona is still alive.
So you should be fine.
Kill me man.
Kill me.
Okay.
Stay alive.
There's like a whole squad there.
Super goona please.
Pew!
No!
Oh!
They can die too!
Yeah!
That's right you can't thirst me!
I was gonna say it would be funny if super goona like DCs you know while we're waiting.
I'm just kidding.
Oh no.
Live for 30 seconds.
We can't rely on super goona.
It's like the timer's almost gone for DC.
Like...
He won't be able to come back soon.
We can't use this.
Super goona.
Where did you...
His outlet is used for...
Where are they anyway?
Like I don't know.
I heard a footstep.
Where are they?
Alright.
I'm heading over.
I see them.
Ping ping them?
Oh that's where they are.
Yeah like around them.
Alright.
I am dropping over here on this high ground.
If I die I die.
I don't see them.
Oh I see them.
They're here.
On that high ground but he dropped down.
Oh I see him.
I have to knock one of them.
50?
He's scared.
Wait wait wait.
I'm gonna get two more bullets.
Wait wait.
I don't know if that's smart.
It will be.
Okay.
I'm heading over.
I'm here with you.
Splash!
I'm missing all my shots.
No!
He's literally one shot shot.
He's running inside.
Got him?
Nice.
It's not a wipe though.
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa.
Doesn't matter.
Maybe I should too.
That's fucking right.
We want your loot.
That's right.
Oh!
Teammate's here.
This is gonna be funny.
This is a funny strat.
Wait his teammate...
Oh I see you.
I see you.
You're gonna wait until your teammates spawn back?
Hello.
Pussy.
Where you at?
He's up there.
He's waiting for his teammates to spawn back in before he does anything.
This is gonna be the funniest strat ever.
Guys we missed...
We don't have SuperGuna anymore.
SuperGuna is not...
No we don't have him.
He's not our...
Our emergency contact is gone.
Wait what the fuck?
On me.
On you?
He went to get his... yeah yeah right here.
I don't know why he was here.
Fresh tactical on hits with ultimate.
Ultimate... improved tactical dumple jump.
I actually don't know which is good.
Me neither.
Where did he go?
I don't think anyone uses Vantage.
There there.
Yeah they said they buffed him but like...
Where?
In what aspect?
Like her sniping?
Like damage is higher now.
This guy over there.
How do we push this?
I don't know I'm trying to...
50...
125...
They're literally one.
This guy is literally one HP.
One of them is.
Oh I did a leg jump.
Oh!
There's people fighting.
Oh they're hard fighting.
Oh we're doing this.
Uh... if you want to.
They're right here I see them.
Full kill Felka.
Full kill.
I saw it.
I saw the full kill.
There's another team over here in front of me.
What!
I missed!
Oh shi...
Okay fuck that guy in particular though.
Right here.
Knocked him.
Full dead?
He's right here.
Anymore?
Yeah inside inside inside.
Whoa!
Alright goodbye!
Bleed out!
Bleed out right now!
If I bleed out it'll add like another 10 seconds.
Yeah but like...
There's no way I'm gonna fucking clutch that.
If it's a full team.
10 seconds.
It's okay I can fly.
Yeah yeah yeah I know you can.
Okay.
Not anymore.
I'm gonna hide in this.
I'm gonna hide here.
Hello welcome to my...
Okay see everything's fine.
I just realized I did not loot any shields.
Do I have shields?
That's my question.
I'm looking around for some shields right now.
I have cells.
Like a lot of cells.
I feel like...
I feel like the command lines I made definitely fixed a lot.
Chat has it improved a lot?
Has it improved a lot?
I repaired my game.
That's good.
It feels like it improved a lot.
I feel like I have less studies now.
We did it guys!
We tech supported our way out!
Even though I should have done this before the stream.
But we did it!
We never gave a fuck about the game.
I'm just...
Wait I hear...
Wait they're literally on me.
Holy shit!
Live!
How do I live?
I don't know!
I'm literally scared!
How do I live?
You were supposed to live!
I'm literally scared!
Literally scared bro!
How do I live?
Wait does that scan me?
Yes.
They're fighting!
Live!
I'm in my safe spot right now so live!
Can you put the guard up?
I'm in my safe spot.
A footstep above you!
Fancy!
They're right next to me!
Live for four seconds!
Four more seconds!
There's a Loba!
Last zone!
Where do I drop though?
I don't fucking know!
Pick a place!
They'll chase me!
I don't know!
Pick a place!
Just away from me!
You think that's a good idea?
Yes!
100% I'll pick the ring then.
Right here?
I'll pick the ring.
Okay.
This map wants me to go down.
Straight.
There are people in front of me.
Oh my god I'm going to ring two!
I don't even know where I'm at.
I'm slowly heading towards you.
Just live!
That's all I ask!
Oh what?
That didn't hit?
I'm sad.
Now they know I'm here.
I'm going to leave next to mine.
Oh my god.
Wait, enemies are respawning right next to me.
Yeah well, there's an enemy camping next to me.
Oh okay.
This is not good.
No it's not.
It's not good at all.
I am...
going to be in zone soon?
I'm in zone.
I'm just ratting.
I'm in zone right here.
Me too.
I'm ratting.
I have my double mozam.
I'm in zone.
It's stopped.
Just live!
I'm ratting.
Rats.
We are the rats.
Technically in zone.
I believe in us.
Oh my god I hear... people are dying and ring?
How?
I've looked at the same guy three times dying in the ring.
Okay there should be no respawn now.
I'm pretty sure.
I think respawns turn off.
So like us being super separated is not very ideal now.
It is not.
Oh ho ho ho ho ho.
How do I get out of here?
Oh ho ho ho.
Holy shit is it real?
Oh ho ho ho ho.
This is the ring.
I messed up.
I don't know how to get out of here.
I messed up too.
Now they will go to my house.
Oh ho ho ho.
Okay.
Live.
We just gotta live.
That's how we're gonna do it.
Ho ho ho ho.
Okay there's no respawn left.
I'm pretty sure.
Right?
Is respawn off now?
Okay I'm gonna figure it out when you die.
I ran away.
How did I run away?
What the fuck?
Bro I ran away.
I literally ran away.
Okay I'm gonna go in like 20 seconds.
One of us will live.
I hope it's you.
Okay.
Bro I don't even have a third gun right now.
I lived.
For now.
Oh god this is bad.
What do you mean the enemy is respawning?
How?
Oh that means his respawn is not off yet.
Oh we could have died.
I don't know where people are.
That's like the scary part.
Freaky.
It's so freaky.
Holy shit what the fuck.
I'm gonna die.
What?
This shit is goaty.
Holy shit.
What is even happening?
I'm goon.
You're what?
Nah bro.
Nah nah nah nah.
How do I get out of here?
How do I cross the road without getting shot by people?
I crossed the road.
No.
Me too.
Hoor hoor hoor.
We can meet up.
We're next to each other.
That's my purpose.
Aha.
So good to finally meet you.
It's been a while.
What you been doing man?
What you been doing?
How's the family man?
How's the family?
You know.
Bro I haven't seen you in like 20 years.
It's been a while.
Yeah.
The family is good.
You got that promotion you've been waiting for?
We've been trying to get it?
Oh no no.
I got fired.
Not yet.
You're still working at that dead end job?
I got fired.
You got fired man?
They told me to not be you know.
Wearing pants is apparently a must in the job.
And I don't like wearing pants.
Bro.
Was that in the contract?
I didn't think so.
Then you should sue them.
That's a lawsuit right there.
They can't discriminate against you.
Hahaha.
That's a bit fashionism.
Don't you think?
I don't know which way.
Should we go outside or like inside?
Do we split up again?
Inside because someone's in the fucking top floor.
No?
Yeah but we have to go outside eventually.
Right?
Yeah right.
But there's that funny looking thing.
And they're not all.
It's a high ground.
A high high ground?
Oh no.
Like above us.
Like that that.
This is not good for us.
Oh I think it will be.
Here here.
This way this way this way.
Maybe?
Yeah yeah there's a door right there.
That's what I'm saying.
Like if we could just take over that area.
It would be funny to see them.
Jikiki.
Orr orr orr.
Orr orr orr orr.
Okay.
Orr orr orr.
Jikiki.
I'm scared.
Do you have enough nades for this?
Oh they have an arc star.
They have a lot of things.
They have a fucking thing.
Don't worry.
I have this.
You have what?
How are we doing this?
I don't know.
I'm going to throw 20 nades.
Oh that's not good.
That's not good.
I need you to break that then.
You gotta break it.
You gotta break it earlier.
Bro you gotta break that earlier bro.
You gotta break it.
We could have kicked it together.
Yeah.
I got the nades.
AHH.
These highgrounds are f- Holy shit this is stupid.
I fucking hate this map.
That's stupid.
I hate the high high ground.
Bro I hate this.
I hate this.
That's embarrassing.
Bro I'm murdering people.
Bro fuck the high high ground.
Like.
I'm sorry people.
Get off the high ground.
I will commit the vehicular manslaughter.
Oh my god.
You don't have the license for it man.
Okay.
We sort of low-key fixed our... we sort of low-key fixed it.
Honestly, it's good that I fixed it.
Does yours feel better too?
Kind of, yes.
Because I have a tournament ticket.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We sort of low-key fixed it a little bit.
But I'll still get the RAM because I feel like...
I don't feel comfortable that my memory is at 90%.
That does not feel right.
I don't feel comfortable at all.
So I'm going to go grab it and see if I can find one that has 32 gigabytes per stick.
But it was fun.
I had a great time.
We kept the tradition up.
We finally did.
We skipped once.
Yeah, we skipped once.
That season doesn't matter.
This season had more stuff in it.
So it mattered more.
The last season didn't have as many updates as this season.
So...
But GG's, man.
GG's.
I will get my breakfast.
Alright.
Oh yeah.
It's breakfast time.
It is like 6.24 AM.
Jesus Christ.
Alright.
But it's been great.
I had a great time.
I'll see you later, dude.
Yay, yay.
Thanks for inviting me.
Bye.
Of course.
Gotta keep that tradition up.
Alright.
Bye-bye.
Bye.
Well, that was fun.
I'm glad we have like tech support on the stream as we went along.
It definitely felt so much better compared to like...
It felt... The game felt so much better compared to like how it was in the beginning.
Because like the beginning was very rough.
It was very very rough.
So...
I'm happy we like fixed it a little bit.
I hope like it was still fun to watch even though...
Even though like...
The stream was really really rough.
I'm really scuffed as we went along.
So even though I hope you guys still enjoyed watching it with the stutters and everything.
So I'm sorry.
I told you guys I'm so unlucky.
I'm so unlucky.
But a great time!
I had a great time.
Today I'll go check out... I'll try and get the fix with the RAM today.
And get that over with.
But I'll see if I can put the RAM in myself.
I'll try my best everybody.
Anyway guys, I'm gonna call it here everybody.
As always everyone, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!